What's for dinner?
And...
Oh, he had spicy noodles.
And it was... it's painful.
Ah!
Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
welcome man how am I doing today I am so sleepy I am so
sleepy what flavor it was a pad thai and I didn't think it
would be spicy and it was spicy I've never tried it before
not that I haven't tried pad thai before but I've never
tried like this place, this, this brand's pad thai.
And I'm like, no!
I've never had a pad thai that was spicy.
Oh, white girl.
I know.
Hey!
Oh my gosh.
When I was in Japan, One of my idols, I was talking, oh not
one of my idols, one of my Ooshes, I was talking to her.
And, uh, she was, she was holding, uh, she was holding a
coke, like a, a Coca-Cola.
And she goes, she goes, she has like the cutest, most baby
soft cotton candy voice.
And she goes,
which means like it's my it's the first ever it's my first
ever cola in my life and i was like what do you what and she
was like i can't have i can't have uh carbonation and i was
like me too i can't have a carbonation either and she was
like and then she goes and then i would go i go what about
spicy food and she goes i can't have spicy food either and i
go it's fate i know it's fate i know it's a rewind time yeah
the reason i chose retro rewind today i know a lot of people
were like why isn't she playing tomobachi live i just i my
brain is recovering back from my trip i was not only jet
lagged but i was like literally thrown into absolute
chaosness that i like i mean there was stuff that i needed
to catch up on and then also just like both nights i've been
up until like two three a.m working on work so um we can
play it tomorrow though we'll play it tomorrow tomorrow or
saturday uh we'll see we'll see Yeah, but I just wanted
something that, this game, I could kind of turn my brain
off.
I was like, I probably won't be, oh, sorry, I was, uh, I, I
was, I probably won't be, I'm like, so, well, going from
apple juice, baby, the spicy, spicy noodles.
How fast do they grow?
No, I'm still the baby.
Happy Koharu Day.
It is Koharu's birthday.
I hope you were able to take Frogbert somewhere nice last
night.
Sounds like Frogbert only wanted the best of the best.
I know.
That guy has high standards.
Thank you for the super chats.
Thank you.
Damien.
Spending my birthday alone.
No.
You're not alone.
You're here with us.
Happy birthday, Damien.
Happy birthday.
I was in shock no Tomodachi.
Yeah.
Actually, it's Tomodachi.
You would be in shock that it's no Tomodachi because that's
not the word.
But yeah, I don't know.
I feel like I am still so...
Ha-k me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
So...
Sorry that I am.
Not playing it today.
I, yeah.
Also, I know some people really enjoy, like, the character
creation aspects of games.
But to me, it's not that I don't, but it's, like, sometimes,
especially when it's, like, too much customization, it
becomes daunting for me.
And I was like, I just don't have the mental capacity to be
in character creation hell for...
hours haven't been catching many streams lately you've just
noticed the two years of membership
thank you thank you so much for doing this overjoyed and two
years thank you choice paralysis yeah right which i guess
like you don't have to make them you know so detailed the
game kind of lets you make them as detailed or as little
detailed as you want which is great but I love character
creation.
I really like people that like character creation.
So, I had a dream last night.
I fought in a gladiator arena for your honor.
I lost all my limbs in combat, but I won.
I'm proud of you.
Just hop in by to say hi, Minto.
Good luck with the work, Phil.
But we are not playing that game today.
So, oh, chat on social media.
screen is frozen.
Why does this keep happening?
YouTube is so stupid.
Thank you.
We're not playing that today.
So, we will save Tomodachi talk for when Tomodachi happens.
Can I reserve the T-Rex in the search for hot dogs?
That's like our most sought after movie.
So, you're gonna have to get in the queue of 1,000 million
55 people.
Do you have any copies of Freaky Ghost Mades 3?
They made a third one?
I named my new bearded dragon V-talk!
Oh my gosh.
I saw a video the other day of of of this guy was just like
my cats are surrounding this wall fixture in my hallway and
it's kind of he made like a funny video being like what in
the poltergeist is going on with my cats why are they all
staring at this light fixture like it's like it's the tv
screen in the poltergeist and at first he was just like he
ha ha moment but then days passed and he was wait this is
kind of weird like why are they why are they still staring
at this live fixture and and they were like sniffing around
they were just hanging out and eventually one of them like
on like takes the the light out of the wall and he's like oh
my gosh do I need to actually call an exorcist what is going
on and turns out he like hangs out with them a little bit
and he sees it he sees he sees a little tiny head poking out
from behind the light and it's just the tiniest lizard you
would ever expect to ever see and it reminded me that
sometimes pause she will kind of like freak out by the
window and I'll look outside because there might be like a
squirrel or a cat or something and I'll be like there's
nothing there pause what are you staring at and then
sometimes if I just stare with her long enough it's the same
thing will happen to me the same thing will happen to me and
I'll see like a little head poke out lizard.
I have like a lizard that lives in one of my windows.
And it drives pies crazy.
I love cats being fascinated by any other living creature.
It's so funny because like cats love lizards for like like
they love them an ungodly amount.
I think it's because lizards are like so, I don't know, like
They're not fuzzy, like a mouse or, you know, anything like
that.
Aren't you glad we live in the timeline, Wind Lizard?
Absolutely.
Like, Lizards are just kind of, like, funky little guys.
We see that lizard every stream.
What are you talking about?
No, you don't.
The way they move stimulates cat brains so much.
That's so funny.
Lizards.
I want a bearded dragon.
Maybe Vinto is cat.
Minkity, minkity.
Maybe.
Are my two stinkies doing well?
Yeah, they're good.
Is this a reptile propaganda stream?
Every stream is reptile propaganda.
We're gonna proper and we're gonna gander at the reptiles.
This means we know you the cat likes lizards.
I was almost late for stream.
I didn't get, I took a nap, a small nap, and I couldn't get
out of bed because Paz was laying on me.
And that's why I cooked my dinner late.
I didn't know how to get her off of me.
She was on my legs.
Ha-da!
This week, woke up to our cats fighting.
We found a window screen torn open.
Some animal had broken in and the cats chased them off.
It came back to market scent.
Oh my gosh.
Is it pause or is it pause?
paws.
It's P-A-Z.
Paws.
It's neither P-A-W-S or P-A-U-S-E.
It's paws.
P-A-Z.
Paws.
Skinwalker probably.
Dogs that look too close to humans.
I think skinwalk is really skinwalkers.
I think they're real.
Happy to ears, Minto.
Thank you souls!
Is that why you like snakes so much since they're also
reptiles i just like reptile i like anything scaly i really
i don't know there's something like there's such a gap moi
between reptiles you know because they act so cute but they
you know they're supposed to look like a little A little
spooky.
Softmighten, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Gapamoy reptiles.
Love it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you a fan of the Komodo dragon?
I'm literally a fan.
I don't think there's a lizard I'm not a fan of.
Like...
I think I see lizard and I'm like...
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes!
Crocodiles!
Lizard!
Yes!
Geckos!
Two years on the go!
Thank you!
Salamander.
I do like them, but they're a little like slimy.
Chameleon?
Love a chameleon.
Love how slow they are.
Lizard, lizard, lizard.
Lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard.
Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard.
Let me try again.
Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard,
Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, Lizard, do.
And I saw something kind of upsetting about that.
Lizard, yes.
Anyone has a translator?
You know that, you know that tongue twister The tongue
twister Fuzzy was a bear Fuzzy was he had no hair Fuzzy was
he wasn't fuzzy was he That's what I said But as a lizard
The thing about that tofu Snake Was I saw You know like I
saw the snake that hits mark a plier And I was like That's
so funny But then Apparently She keeps like The owner of the
snake keeps like putting pictures of Markiplier in the
snakes like house and stuff and like he doesn't obviously
that's like stressing him out and then I also saw another
video of someone saying that you know the reason that he
might not like Markiplier is because he saw Markiplier when
like something bad happened to him and so he associates
Markiplier with with like that moment
I don't...
It makes me sad, but it's just like, oh, look at this silly
animal moment, and it's actually like trauma behind it.
Yeah, that's not cozy at all.
Sorry to be the buzzkill of if you really enjoyed that
video.
Is that actually happening, or is it a rumor?
It was... I don't have any evidence.
It was someone who was like, I owe...
I take care of snakes and this is my speculation so but also
apparently that girl has like passed the girl who owns the
snake has like passed bad she's bad news bears with past
animal treatment apparently I don't know anything about All
I saw was the snake.
Why can't we just love animals and have fun?
Marketplier PTSD is real.
I got diarrhea during Iron Lung and now I can't think of
a...
Let me play time now.
Feeling cautious.
Was it...
Was it all the sloshing?
Or was it his outfit that really made your tummy go...
Oh, no.
What?
What was it that made you have?
Maybe the popcorn.
No, it couldn't be.
Sloshing.
Yeah, it wasn't... I actually haven't seen Iron Lung, but
doesn't like...
His whole little ship fills up with stuff.
Yeah, maybe.
Diarrhea-inducing pecs.
I think I would also get diarrhea too.
if I was like...
I'll never be him!
Oh,
it was with the blood.
Ew!
The movie is like 50% blood.
All I know about Mark is that his pecs are massive and iron
long.
Doesn't he wear like a slutty little like course not a
corset like a harness or something that's all i heard about
yes same she does
where can i watch it mark a poor markiplier getting the leon
kennedy treatment Poor Johnny Ibu!
We got close-ups of it.
No way.
Apparently now Jacksepticeye is making a Bloodborne movie.
But also...
Did you guys...
I actually didn't watch it.
Did you guys see the Street Fighter movie?
What is going on?
You should check out what Cobras and...
What...
Oh, and boom slangs look like before they puff themselves
up.
too.
Oh, we're striking.
With the snakes?
I mean, though, I'm so glad I got to spend so much of this
past year with you.
Couple!
Happy birthday!
Thank you!
It looks pretty funny, eh?
The Street Fighter movie?
I want to...
I will watch the trailer after.
Snake's burrowing.
Oh, I love when snakes burry in the sand and they go like
this.
You know?
They stick their whole nose in and they go.
I love that.
Time to watch Buito.
Hi.
I've been seeing the older Street Fighter movie.
I feel like they are aiming for that kind of energy.
Actually, I haven't.
Minto Gear Solid movie.
I couldn't make a Metal Gear Solid movie.
Nothing would live up to my standards.
I will commend others for trying if they do.
But I could not do it myself.
Because I would just be like, no.
Again.
No.
Like every take, you know.
Okay, okay!
You must feel the emotion!
I would be like, okay, now we're actually...
Like, you must...
Actually be torture-shocked.
I need the realism.
Dragon Ball...
Picture Dragon Ball Evolution, but it doesn't take itself
seriously at all.
Wait, okay, I also...
I also did not watch Dragon Ball Evolution.
Did it take itself seriously?
I thought it didn't.
Well, I mean, based on how it looked.
What's your perfect Metal Gear live-action cast?
I don't know.
Because I don't know actors.
Lizzie McGuire's dad as Otacon is all I got.
The snake is too hard to cast because he needs to have no
eyes and he needs to be able to speak without moving his
lips.
He needs to have pixel pecs and...
Young Kurt Russell.
So true.
Probably, I mean, like that guy, that guy, no, that guy is
Pliskin.
That guy is Pliskin.
I used to keep horn sand vipers, and sometimes in the middle
of the night, I could hear them shimmy in the sand.
But I'm even rolling.
Oh, I'm clutching my chest, so it hurts a bit.
Ah, so cute.
I'm like that meme of that old man.
She's so cute.
Ryan Gosling as Master Miller.
Actually, Ryan Gosling could probably do a really great
cause.
Maybe.
Haley Joel Osman as Ocelot.
Do you want to be banned?
Do you want it?
Gosling or Reynolds?
Wait, did I mix it up?
No.
Uh, Ryan Gosling is the one in uh, uh, Project Hail Mary.
I heard Reynolds, but maybe you said Gosling.
Wait, what did I say?
Wait, no, I don't know!
Ah!
Wait, wait, wait!
I said Gosling.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gosh, why are they so similar?
I need to turn DVR on, so I know what I said.
It's just those two that I just seriously...
Well, it's also because I don't know so many actors and
actresses, too.
I can, like, recognize some people, but I never know their
names either.
Fell for the old Ryan Ruse.
The old Ryan Ruse.
Yeah.
We have the live transcript.
Reynolds is Deadpool.
What else has Ryan Reynolds been in?
All I know of is Deadpool.
Now that I think about it...
Does that guy have a career?
What else is that guy doing?
Oh, he was Pikachu!
Wait, he was Pikachu?
Wait, was he Pikachu?
Or was he just in Detective Pikachu?
Ryan Reynolds Pikachu.
Oh!
No way.
Why do they always get the stinkiest people to voice like
these Nintendo characters?
What?
Chris Pratt as Paz.
He'll be like, Hey guys, it's me, Paz.
I don't know what Chris Pratt sounds like.
Hey, guys, it's me, Paz.
Um, I love peace.
It's me, Mario.
Jack Black is liquid.
We'll just take the whole Mario cast and push them into the
Metal Gear movie.
That means, uh, uh, what's his name?
The guy from Always Sunny, who plays Luigi, he will be
Ocelot.
Charlie Day.
Charlie Day will be Ocelot, and then, uh, Jack Black can be
Liquid.
Danny Defeat.
Danny Davido can be Kero-Tan in the backgrounds of MGS3.
Just put him in a frog suit and have him in the background.
Jason Boboa is Psycho Mantis.
With his luscious locks.
Did you guys see the rock with hair?
He's like...
Oh, what's his name?
From Moana.
Maui.
That's how I feel if you were to make... If you were to
reverse it and make Jason Mamoa bald for Psycho Mantis.
It's like giving the rock hair.
Jason Mamosa.
He looks like weird Al.
It's so bad.
It's so funny.
I thought I saw...
Wait.
I thought I saw a trailer for something coming out that I
was like, oh, that looks interesting.
But I can't remember what it was.
He still looks bald.
I know!
Like, it just looks bald.
Like, it looks like a bald man.
and wearing a wig.
I saw a trading card of you at a con recently.
I didn't buy it because to me, you're priceless.
Wait, a trading card!
I don't know.
I have a trading card.
Weird Alice Sniperwolf.
What is this casting?
I can't...
If this were the casting, I couldn't tell.
I don't think I'd be able to tell.
If people would really hate it, hate the movie.
Or if they'd be like, this is God-cast.
Hi, Minta.
Hi, baby boy.
Slopcast.
Daniel Radcliffe is decoy on the movie.
He was not even in the movie.
Liquid Snake singing a rock song about asymmetry theory on
top of Rex...
Reckish.
Adam Sandler a snake.
Oh gosh, it's just getting worse.
The MGS fandom is pretty peculiar with their taste to enjoy
a meme cast.
Oh, particular.
They are peculiar, too.
No, I agree.
I think a lot of Metal Gear fans are very serious about the
series.
So I think that if, like, a meme cast were to come out, they
would be very...
They would be, like...
they would burn it to the ground
it would be so funny though it would be pretty funny just
gotta not take things so seriously Keanu Reeves I watched
John Wick 2 actually I fell asleep during John Wick 2 and
then I woke up and it was over the music sounds like
ghostbusters wait did i say john wick or alan wait i saw
john wait did i say john wait is it i say john wick wait no
it's no it's alan wake at the lake john wick no i said it
right i said it Alright, Rufus, thank you so much for the
best he can do.
Thank you!
Stop confusing me!
I said it right, I said it right.
John Wick.
John Lake.
No, sorry.
John Lake is my OC, okay?
Do not steal him.
He is my original character, and he goes into the Alan Wake
Lake.
John Lake is the lake, actually.
Metal Gear Movie Cast has to be Tom Cruise in all roles
since Kurt Russell doesn't want to.
to be sick.
Two years.
Thank you, Evan!
Johnny awake.
Was he a writer?
No, he's a lake.
He's all water.
He's a body of water.
They broke the mold after they made you, thankfully.
What the hell does that even mean, Murphy?
Never change Retro Port.
I don't know what I'm saying.
more
if he made bread it would be John Bake Maple why can't we
have the wake like multiverse Alan Wake Alan Bake Alan what
else rhymes with um Alan quake, Alan shake.
That's the same thing, Kyle.
Alan make.
Alan steak.
That is...
Hell's Kitchen.
Can you stay jet lagged for a few more streams?
This is peak.
A click.
My bad.
Oh, what the heck is happening?
Wait, hold on.
Oh, there.
Wait, why is the game being weird now?
Oh, there we go.
Reynolds versus Gosling and Wick versus Wake back to back.
Nothing ever changes.
It's been years.
Ryan Reynolds, Ryan Gosling.
It has been years that I have been fighting.
internally with these two and sometimes like oh I was
telling my friend or yeah I was telling my friend about
Project Hail Mary and I was like yeah Ryan Reynolds isn't it
and they were just like you mean Ryan Gosling like I do it
off stream I can't help it it's not a bet I guess
I'm tired of this afterlife.
Expecting you to go ham on Tomodachi Live.
Yeah, I already explained it at the beginning of the stream.
I just am too tired for it.
The easy difference is one is literally you and the other is
Ryan Reynolds.
I'm Ryan Gosling?
Wait, what makes me like Ryan Gosling?
Is it the soft boy energy that he exudes?
Is it because he wears...
cardigans and well I guess he only wore cardigan in the
Project Hail Mary.
Guy's Ling is goofy.
My guy is kind of goofy.
Wait I gotta blow my nose.
I'm testing my nose.
I think I gotta blow again.
I won't mute this time.
This town's not big in for two famous ryan's one's gotta go
i agree ryan gosling is literally me thank you for your
super chat ryan or should i say mr gosling i don't know you
i don't i don't know him to say his name do you guys ever
feel that way like with celebrities and stuff i feel weird
saying like oh i love
work but like referring to them by just their first name
like like i say david hater i never say david like i have to
say david hater or like ryan gosling you know like i just
can't say like a jack black you know like it's a full name
thing i agree miss phantom no no oh my gosh bronson thank
you so much for The fifth thing is it!
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Tom Hank or Tom Cruise, Minto?
Wait, Tom Hank.
Is he box of chocolates?
What is...
Some people call Brittany Spears Brittany and not Spears.
I call her Brittany Spears.
She's also another full-name person.
Okay.
Tom Cruise is Mission Impossible guy.
Tom Cruise is Top Gun guy.
Tom Hank.
Here.
I feel like I've watched not so...
Well, okay, wait.
I can...
Let me name a couple of movies he's been in.
Toy Story.
Force Gump.
Wasn't he in the Green Mile?
A castaway.
But I feel like...
Oh, besides those...
movies i have not seen him in like so much and
tom cruz i think i've only seen him in top guide
saving private ryan i didn't see that
he was in big what is big me i'm huge i'm big i'm i'm
humongous I'm so I'm so big they need to put a light at the
top of me into worn planes and and helicopters make a cute
wink um have make make a make a manners and say please
minkey why you lying I am always serious I never lie.
Please?
Wink kudasai.
Alright.
A nice, a nice, a nice close-up.
I forgot I was going to play a game.
I thought I just had a BGM on.
I forgot.
I thought I was going to play a game today.
And face up on Bruce, thank you so much for the tour again.
Okay.
I'm awake.
Hold on, let me pinch myself.
Okay.
Maybe I should get some coffee.
Oh, let's chop it up.
Okay.
Let's go.
Last time we played this.
our storage value is almost three thousand dollars baby in
in in modern day times that's like
one million dollars never knew you and Phoebe became friends
on the island because of six seven it was beautiful to see
I'm sure it was
I'm level nine Okay, let's go.
Dogs and dynos.
Everybody?
Wait, why does my employee look distressed?
Is it because this man is following so close behind you?
Oh, he's fine now.
Tom Cruise will always be Lestat.
Tom Hanks will always be Gump.
Keanu will always be...
Who the heck is Ted?
Wait, what do you mean Keanu will be Ted?
Nobody knows.
Who is Ted?
Phantom will always be freaky.
Oh, Bill and Ted!
No, Keanu will always be Alan Wake.
I'd rather not thank you so much for the tag.
Yitterd!
Alright.
I don't remember what we were doing.
Rough night boss, you look tired this morning.
I don't want to hear it from you, Ryan.
Oh, Ryan!
Everyone's a Ryan.
We got Ryan Battles.
We got Ryan Gosling.
And we have a Ryan at my movie store.
I can't get away from you guys.
Why?
Why is
that?
My middle name is a Ryan.
Band.
Ryan Rent.
The famous Ryan crash out of 2026.
We did expand though.
I thought that said 13 bones.
I was like, wait.
That's like half of what the human body has.
It would be like a puddle.
If you had 13 bones.
Yeah, doesn't the human body only have 26 bones?
What do you mean it's 206?
Wait, did I just...
Wait, what do you mean?
Did I...
Did
I just remove the zero?
I cannot... I could... I do not see.
26 teeth no bones bones bones you're thinking of chromosome
pairs who
any thoughts on haley joel osman get out of here get out of
here well you're away on my ibu varsity i'm generally new to
the v2 world had such a fun time with you Thank you!
After a mothman and kill her.
I might have 13 bones.
Look at this!
Who ordered the hot T-Rex?
The hot dog of my fantasy.
Look at our selection.
It's too good, it's too good.
We got to expand here.
Oh, I was like, what the hell am I hearing?
Turn down.
Shut up.
Is this a new release day?
No.
Today's a normal day.
What is this?
What movie...
Are bad dreams released?
Wait.
Oh.
Huh.
I don't know what we're doing.
Tape guy shows up today though.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Oh!
We got...
Uh...
Christmas movies.
Alright, we're gonna have to put some...
movies on the ground.
Happy that's your back, Lavi.
Thank you, Lavi!
Our plant pods first date!
Christmas already?
I don't think it's even been Halloween.
Where's that movie?
The sculpture on Christmas morning.
That looks a little ominous.
All right, let's buy some more shelving for our Christmas
movies here.
That's what we gotta do.
Oh, I can't.
I have $90.
Yeah, I think it's still Halloween, though.
Halloween's coming up.
It's fall.
It's fall, baby.
I got no money.
Routro.
Urm.
Well, the romance...
We'll just put it on this one romance shelf for now.
The last dinosaur...
Wait, that's a horror movie, isn't it?
Yeah.
This is horror.
more space for.
Oh yes I do.
I'm a heckin' liar.
Xmas.
Xmas makes it seem kind of spicy though.
The game was updated since last.
There's a tape rack by the shipping deck and shelves for
large boxes.
A tape rack.
Oh my god!
And a shipping deck and shelves... wait.
Wait, wait, you're speaking too fast.
What did you say?
Wait, what?
You're saying...
Wait, say that again.
There's a tape rack by the shipping deck and shelves for
large boxes.
Shelves for large boxes.
Like this?
Okay.
Love to have you back, Vito's skill for you.
X-ray!
I have no money!
Please don't.
If it's not, thank you so much for that tag, get that, thank
you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you some...
This shelf?
Maybe is the shelf.
Shelf for boxes.
What's up?
What's...
Why do I need boxes?
Since there was an update, do we have more...
We have a nutcracker.
Snacks.
Stations.
Shelves.
For furniture.
Oh.
I'll just place the furniture.
Okay, let's do our movies and such.
Wait, I should have...
I'm gonna assign a job to you.
Assign return station.
Okay.
I should have had him been doing the job while I do nothing.
Oh, if you need to put Sandeys away!
Oh, I see.
Good job.
I'll do this.
I'll do this part.
Oh, new release, new release.
Yes, new release, new release.
Oh, yeah.
We do have a new release.
Oh, come on.
Woo!
Thank you, welcome to membership!
Oh, my hands are full.
Oh, were you waiting on me, my bud?
What the hell?
Why'd you put it down there?
The weightlifter who have followed you home.
My gay movie section right here.
That's that guy.
Now you're thinking like a manager.
Wait, I have to rearrange all of this.
Oh.
The slow turn?
That's why you're the boss, boss.
Okay.
We'll put that there.
What are you doing?
Don't ruin it.
Don't ruin my setup.
We have even a shiny static.
What does it say?
A static haunting.
The side eye kills me.
Are you doing a good job, Ryan?
don't stare at me that means you're not working oh golly
he's slow okay we can get in here now what is it what did i
say was it late maybe we have a shiny of both oh snake says
oh you were waiting on me my bud one day they will invent a
home video technology that you won't have to rewind and
maybe it can hold more than a movie like deleted scenes that
sounds really um you're getting your hopes pretty high i'd
say oh we don't have enough room and i have no money to buy
more shelves on the floor oh my god no on the floor on the
floor
No, my floor movies!
My floor movies!
My floor movie!
You think people will still, they'll be like, why is this on
the floor?
That's so fascinating.
I'm so intrigued of why this movie could be on the floor.
I like how we get like the, oops.
The quiet time with the dinosaur.
Along with
all I need is my fast food.
Yes, yes.
What is it?
Bad dreams on Mel Road.
Who broke it?
They created the first dynamite.
Let the movies hit the...
Oh,
he liked that one.
He liked that one.
Wait, what do you mean, mixed?
No, no, no, no, no.
No!
This is the action section!
What else did you put here?
No!
What are you doing, Ryan?
Wait.
This is all wrong.
Okay, now it's action.
Wait, unless this was the mix section.
I can't remember action.
Wait, I can't remember.
Bad Ryan.
He's gonna do it again.
Wait, is there no...
There's no room for sci-fi.
I can't find any empty science fiction or make shelves to
place the science fiction movies.
Oh.
The floor.
Uh...
You can go back to the checkout.
What is he gonna do with those?
He looks so distressed.
Stop taking your job so serious.
I am firing you.
It's so cold.
Action means the people move.
That's all movies.
A scientist and a snake.
Once we have room, we'll, uh...
Okay.
There you go.
No, no, don't leave.
Ooh.
Yes.
Catch them before they leave.
Well, you're all coming over anyway.
You love my store.
What's wrong?
Yes?
Yes, you did.
This guy is so eager.
He just called.
All right, we're already getting movies back.
Reserved.
Very good.
He really wants it.
tell.
I can tell.
Bing.
Good job, team.
Oh, I have...
A plant pot.
I have a special...
I forgot that I can put my shinies in here.
This is a horror movie, right?
Yeah.
Very nice.
Good.
Good, good, yes.
Rent my movies.
Spread my code.
Oh, this is...
Wait, why is that on the floor?
Who did that?
Was that me?
I don't think so.
Oh, good, good.
Yes, rent movie.
Very good.
Okay, we need more people in here.
Do you like movies?
Now you do.
You?
Hmm.
Ooh.
Not realizing that once I've never seen you clean this door.
Because literally, I'm like, everyone is so clean.
Oh, hello.
Blood-sucking paladin.
That's disgusting.
There you go.
Yes, yes.
Okay, not yet.
Uh...
Hi!
My ghosts only regret...
Mint judged them?
I don't judge.
I like the strategy.
Movies on the floor like breadcrumbs to guide the customers.
Yes!
It's a very strategic choice, yes.
Yes, indeed.
Hello!
Her.
Yeah.
Ooh, indeed.
Oh, this guy looks angry.
Movie would change that.
This lady looks ready for a movie.
Leave me alone.
Leave me alone, she says.
twins behind you you know they say if you see your
doppelganger you'll die so if you see just close your eyes
wow ruined her day i actually did i feel like i did ruin her
day
oh okay she said thanks at least i guess that's true no
missed customer customer customer customer customer calling
all customers don't you want to support small business thank
you you can be on the on the battlegrounds when my business
goes crazy my love life is pathetic got any romance movies
closer to my dragon you already wait He's a dragon!
He's a dinosaur connoisseur!
Did you see that?
He grabbed the other dino romance movie, too!
Hey.
I think.
Me thinks that somebody...
Table for two with our T-Rex.
There you go.
He's a knower.
Wait, where are all the customers?
Ryan, you're scaring them away.
Hello?
Now you love movies.
What the?
Hit him with the love movie beam.
You love movies!
You love movies Sha!
Oh!
You...
Wait, don't go, don't go, don't go.
Oh, I need more.
You love movies ha!
Ha!
My love life is pathetic.
Got any romance movies?
Why so many people not wanting to come over?
Oh.
My love life is pathetic.
Let me give you the movie.
My dinosaur makes me cool.
It'll make you really appreciate.
Oh, dog!
I'm testing a new monitor.
Can you please make yourself wider?
Why?
How?
Wait, why are nobody renting horror movies?
Don't- don't get a Christmas movie.
It's Halloween.
What's wrong with you?
The client is asking to see a manager.
Oh, never mind.
You keep working.
Yes?
What do you want?
I have a broken fee?
Is this a scam to charge me?
more money i won't pay that charge yeah i don't know what
you broke but it was probably really important to me short
minky why am i short why am i short somebody already
reserved please fix my leaky heirloom that's crazy work wait
are these all horror movies oh shoot we're screwed nobody is
right now for some reason even though it's the season tis
the season trying to wind down from work got any sci-fi um
i've got right here for you the yacht through space did you
rent one of those because if so you're the speediest guy
ever oh my dad left when i was a kid do you have a family
drama to cheer me up also a bad we could make a better
recommendation.
They make me laugh every time.
This guy came up to my counter and trauma dumped on me.
Here, I'll give you a knockout gangster.
Ooh.
Hmm.
Yeah, you have to pay it.
Yeah.
Good job, Ryan, making them pay the fee.
You do the crime.
You do the time.
We only keep good movies.
in this establishment.
Oh, it's renting horror.
How could this be?
Oh my gosh, it's midnight.
Good, they're all paying.
Yes.
Make them pay.
I am.
I'm running a business here.
Not out pixie no that's a late it's pretty bad when the when
a late movie is an adult movie you must have been really
enjoying your time with that one huh i see just you know got
lost in the sauce couldn't keep track of time oops you did a
good job today we're on I did all of that.
Horror movies are still not in great shape.
Tape vendor!
Oh, thank you.
I do have money now.
Hello.
Hello vendor.
Bus tapes in town.
What do you have?
A scary bull in the tent?
I don't think I can buy it because I don't have...
Well...
The ape rock star.
Chocolate-covered statue.
The cougar wants my fairy.
Please fix my leaky husband.
Where'd you
get that one?
I like how his house is literally right here.
Knock knock.
What is this?
Rewinding.
There was a time when every weekend began with a simple
ritual.
I would go there with my parents, excited to rent a movie
for the night.
We would watch it together in the basement where my father
had installed a home cinema sound system so we could truly
share the experience as a family.
In the winter we would sit there while the fireplace
crackled softly in the background watching movies.
Other times.
I rent a video game for the week.
Sometimes they were great, sometimes they were terrible, but
it was always a surprise.
rely on was the box art and the recommendations of the staff
because there were no online reviews or even internet back
then this game was inspired by those childhood memories and
by the story shared by our players i hope it resonates with
you in the way those moments influenced who i became the way
those moments influenced who i became and the game it has
grown into dedicated to my friends and family i love you
what uh i found a wholesome lore oh
Wait, that was so cute!
Aww!
Oh, these are all broken, but they're like the peak of the
peak broken ones.
I can't get rid of them, you know.
Oh, there's boxes here!
Oh, I see, I see!
This does not count.
Okay.
I don't think I have anymore.
Okay, we're gonna have to buy another shelf.
that too all right let's another okay hold on we can
consolidate this a little bit please fix my leaky husband i
think they used to have commercials for that condition
during football games
okay we'll do
i think we gotta do two big row big big big shelves
I could always make it a mixed one, you know?
Um, I think I need a big shelf.
Oh, wait.
I do have a one.
This one will be for the adult movies.
Wait, how do I move again?
Oh, V.
Oh, but how will they see the hot T-Rex?
Ah.
Weigh.
Like here or something.
okay okay like that
oh yeah our selection has expanded and we also have movies
like that if that is your thing don't pop more popcorn at
midnight Ryan this what do you want a snack or something
come on now we can use this wait Okay, hold on.
Oh, oops.
I don't get why you can't move stores behind other movies.
Wait, why you can't store movies behind other movies.
I remember Shells being jeeps enough to...
Ryan!
That's so true.
Poor cashier is just standing there wondering when his shift
will finally end.
When I tell him it will.
You go home and I tell you you can, Ryan.
Yes, you hear that?
I am your boss.
I am your leader.
I am your master.
We gotta decorate this.
No, I keep pressing V instead of V.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
I gotta make it.
This type.
Yeah.
Ryan's eternal suffering.
What he gets for being a Ryan.
Ryan, I don't know what to tell you.
We'll do...
We'll put this here.
And it can be a shelf or something when we need it.
Something.
When we need it.
When we need room.
It will go there.
Good night, Ryan.
Oh, I got 250 movies.
Check in 1,000 movies.
at the return station nice dogs and dinos demolition derby
wait what does that mean whoa look at the city wow wow why
does everyone look so upset and distressed are they okay as
a ryan this has been a stream for me wait i have to punch in
before wait come on man where did you that this is not not
ryan he is once again wearing sunglasses wait he's probably
gonna be like i have a tummy ache you are not ryan wait come
here wait oh i thought that said i am flirting with you
that's terrifying go do the return station cool ryan so what
does this mean action movies 60 of 60 action movie rentals
The dead hobo is alive.
Here are some skews you might enjoy.
Thank you.
Wait, give me one second.
One second.
Will you tell me you have a copy of Who Ordered the Hot
T-Rex?
Gosh, this is so in demand.
People love this movie.
I'm telling you, it's not my fault that my adult movies are
flying off the shelves.
I'm not trying to be an adult.
movie store but i'm just telling you the people in this town
they're hungry let's see six not oh oh this is a this is a
horny movie isn't it nine four two zero two one
i don't have enough money for it but thank you for sharing
His massive instrument strikes again.
I can't tell.
That sounds like a crime.
The dog's part of the family, of course.
It sounds like an assault, you know?
Like he takes his guitar and like smashes your head into...
Or it smashes it into your head, you know?
Thank you for sharing those skews.
I was going to see what we did have for action movies.
Science fan.
The gargoyle's time has come.
Oh my god.
The cover goes hard though.
Drama Christmas.
Ooh, shiny Christmas.
Okay, Christmas.
No action.
The tub gone by midnight.
No, wait, static haunting is not a new rental anymore?
No kidding.
Okay.
That sucks, huh?
Oh my gosh, I gotta blow my nose again, you guys, I'm sorry.
It's because I think all these new... Oh wait, that means
all the static haunting ones we can...
We can like take these And we'll put them on the back shelf
You know This shiny one will go in here Because I like it
And then these will go like out Over here Oops
Yeah Let's organize this a little bit too Alright Actually
Wait yeah Yeah
Wait, no, I want...
I want all the horror movies over here.
There we go.
Oh.
Sure.
William, thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you!
How many more movies we got?
What broke?
My eggs only regret!
No!
No, no, no!
he's so slow
okay rocket dinosaurs okay
uh shoot to the mixed shelf oh to the mixed shelf it's mixed
now this it'll be well all right go back to check it out we
we shall Organize is better.
Charge a rewind fee.
Yeah, we actually I haven't checked the staff.
Like, there could be some really great...
We got James, who's loyal.
Never ask for a right.
Energetic, thick-skinned, does not quit when yelled at to
work faster.
Strong immune system.
Never take a sick day.
Ryan or a sandbuster?
I think this is a real Ryan Oh we have more I think our Ryan
is like Oh he's average average Wait who the hell is this
How wait Ryan is blonde Wait
Huh Well we didn't need energetic So they never he never
falls asleep And the bathroom breaks I think Wait what who
is this who are you all right let's get this day started
baby there's people walking by oh sorry hold on ouch what
did you get a paper cut don't be so dramatic hmm whoa no
don't leave oh yeah Yeah.
Wait, both of them didn't want to?
Employment is the Ryan's we met along the way.
This guy is huge.
Hey.
Hello.
Astro Golf.
Oh, wait, what?
Pick up the movie.
Do you reserve that?
Oh, okay.
Wow.
You're welcome.
Um...
Hmm.
Oh.
Wait, let's give some...
Let's pass these out as well.
Thank you.
Wait, what do you mean?
Who?
You're the one staring at my shop.
You're the one loitering out here.
Don't...
Don't make me call the cops on you now.
Astro Golf.
Do-do-do-do.
I am Astro Golf.
What do you mean?
Fix my leaky heirloom.
You know there's a sequel.
My leaky husband.
Fantastic pic, she says.
We got a bit of a line.
Come on, Ryan.
Keep it together.
Wow.
What do you mean?
Oh.
No.
What do you watch for fun?
What do you do for fun if you don't watch movies?
You read books like a nerd?
It's the 90s.
are all the rage we finally have color come on oh aren't you
isn't that like so exciting and awesome hello sir hello
would you like to come i'm jumping over fences now i'm i'm
desperate for sales i'll do anything
please we're gonna i'm i'm like i'm love live in my my store
right now we're gonna go out of out of business if we don't
have you.
Please, please, please.
Suffer, suffer, suffer.
Look, I'm restocking as we...
As the day goes on, you have to be in here 24-7 to see
everything that we have to offer.
They had color in the 50s.
No, no, no.
Christmas Eve with my letter.
Didn't I just put this up?
Holy cow.
Oh.
You are so fast.
Action.
Drama.
Romance.
Oh my god, lady.
Expert.
timing.
They even had color before the 50s.
No, literally everybody started seeing in color in the 90s.
That's when they invented the eyeballs that could see color.
Before, we were like dogs.
Living dull lives.
Mint is correct.
Thank you.
I know I'm always right.
No, no, no, please.
No!
It sounds like a leaf blower.
It doesn't sound like cars.
I like when they turn around.
Wait, wait.
No, I don't have any more.
Um, hey.
This?
Horror movie.
Psycho killer foot.
Super scary.
10 out of 10 recommend.
Especially if you're in defeat.
Rent the movie.
This is kind of embarrassing, but could you give my number
to whoever was working the cash register?
I thought they were kind of cute.
Ryan that way.
Glad to see you live today, being as cute as Julia Sweet as
ever.
We're absolutely amazing.
Glad to find your dreams.
Seal, thank you.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Ryan has solicitors, you guys.
But also, if you're gonna try...
There's nothing back there for you.
Stop staring at my goldfish.
If you're gonna try and get with one of my employees you
better have the guts to come in here and do it in person
that's the shades wrong number
i heard someone come over to the she went um
yeah they're they're falling for the cooler ryan they're not
they don't know him like we do Wait, what did you need?
Waiting for the release of Bad Dreams on Mel Road.
Oh, sorry, we don't have it.
I cannot help you at the moment.
Sorry.
You just made my day.
Did you mean that?
It seems my attempts to post Ryan from my own video story
have failed.
You'll never get him.
He has loyalty.
Look at him.
Look at the way.
Get someone who smiles at you like the way Ryan's.
smiles at me.
Oh, it's like, hey, boss, I wasn't just stealing money from
the register.
I know you were it, Ryan.
So I'll check the cams later.
You can never...
You can
never...
More people?
Interested in movies?
You like movies now.
Wow, a nice line.
oh my goodness I found this box in the alley behind my
building filled with movies thank you what did we get we got
the vet actually I realized something I'm gonna scoot over
this side I feel like you guys can't see or maybe I go here
I want you guys to be able to see the movies I like shrink
down a little bit i realized that last time i was like dang
i should probably like move you know i'm here to ask out the
cute ghost mid running the video rental store sorry i'm
married to my work the veteran butler action nice mind
reader war zone nice the computer no the book the book
computer Hey?
This client's asking to see a manager.
What's wrong?
You damaged.
The movie I was working fine when I dropped it off.
I won't pay.
Leave me alone.
Guy behind you's having a really nice day.
It's just you, ma'am.
Mint is married for tax purpose.
Why are they looking at me like that.
Ew.
Don't give me that face.
The veteran butler and the cute ghost made it sound like an
Oscar-worthy action movie.
Zoe!
You came late at night.
You came at midnight.
To collect your movie.
I think she's into me.
Oh, she's still looking.
Nice, and she's still getting stuff.
I love a customer like you.
You're the best.
I'm going to watch you purchase.
Nice.
What's that?
The last princess in Blackwood Manor.
And a cozy monster holiday.
Oh, you're a freak, Zoe.
She smiles like she knows it.
She's like, yeah.
Have a good night.
Here, I'll walk you to your car.
It's quiet out here, huh?
It's quiet.
It's not safe for a lady like yourself with your cultured
taste to be walking alone.
Oh.
Have a good night, Zoe.
I'll see you again.
I can't pick it up.
What service?
And she's my loyal customer.
All right.
we're gonna get to level 10 soon baby soon okay we're still
in demolition derby people are still crazy for action movies
we gotta get come on ryan hurry up the real ryan is here or
were you ever ryan did you die your hair the returns are
piling up yeah they are yep that's what you're gonna be
doing while i run around being a goofball.
Yeah, that's your job.
Alright, come here.
Return station.
Do your job.
You found him in a very blonde time of his life.
Oh, Luke.
Hannah is fast and fast.
She does not quit when Dell did work faster.
Wait.
But I would have to fire Ryan.
Is he Ryan or are we Ryan?
I don't think I can get rid of Ryan.
I'm like so attached to him now.
Oh, thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
Why does YouTube have to change the raid message to...
It was white, so it stood out against the black background.
But now it's black, so I can't see it.
And there's also, it used to be at the top of the chat.
Now it's at the bottom.
Thank you, I see it, dude.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you, Raiders.
Targo, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you, Lily.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
Ducky, thank you.
I have thank you, Rose and Koo Choice.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
Sorry, Ryan.
I'm in your way, aren't I?
Yeah.
You keep up the good work.
Can I give these to people?
wow they're oh oh yeah I'm closed my bed
they're so sad all right let's get our action movies all
yeah everything all We're almost out of Christmas movies
even.
We have so many horror movies.
Let's see if we can get any more action movies.
The Buffalo's eternal love.
Till woman do us part!
This was Mother Base.
Ryan would be leech or silver, right?
Okay.
heriting the grandpa.
Oh my god.
Santa and disco queen on watch.
Let's buy five random movies.
See what we get.
I'm obsessed.
The dessert on Christmas morning.
The wraith Santa squad.
Dr. Lane's chosen
Diver Brain Implants.
Okay, well, we did need some more Christmas, so that's
great.
Dr. Lane's chosen hag.
The couple's mailbox.
Oh, good, it's a shiny.
Suck.
A couple of action and drama skews.
Oh, thank you, Paige.
now so
fast dinosaur pursuit noise t-rex burnout
the veteran t-rex okay that one's kind of expensive so the
fast food's wrong number who they calling t-rex gone what
the fuck I want that version of Gone with the Wind.
That one's also kind of expensive.
Thank you, Paige.
Thank you.
Till women do us part.
It's so funny.
It's not even women.
It's woman.
Like, it's a woman singular.
I'm a fan, I'm a fan.
The fast food was calling for Ryan's number.
I think we have the one static haunting.
That's good.
We'll probably rent it eventually.
Because...
Oh, broken!
What?
That's too broken!
No stinking way!
Oh, sorry.
You're waiting on me.
My bad.
Here we go.
I'll start putting these away.
What else was broken?
The blood-sucking bathtub!
No!
Frankly, my dear, I don't give a roar.
Happy Thursday.
Is it Thursday?
Yes.
Happy Thursday!
Reserved.
Popular movies, huh?
Hey, Feliz!
Yay!
Fixed- Oh, leaky heirloom came back.
Where is it?
Where's my leaky heirloom?
There you are.
Oh, shoot.
I just messed it up again.
Where are you?
There you are.
Okay.
Action.
Sci-fi.
Romance.
R-R-A-A-A-A.
R-M-A-M-A.
G-G-G-L-L-A.
I think that's everything.
Okay, Ryan, back to the checkout.
Thank you.
Koharu's birthday, I know.
Oh, so happy it's her birthday.
I don't think I have time to get a cake, though.
You know?
Maybe after stream, I could go get a little sweet treat for
her.
Yeah.
Look at something yummy.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, you love movie.
You love movie.
No, you love movie.
Love movie beam.
Oh, hello.
What can I help you with?
A letter to my breakfast.
Yep.
I put that on the shelf this morning.
No cake for Koharu death penalty!
No!
Why does everyone look?
What'd you get?
Oh, wait, what'd you get?
He's like, I'll never tell.
Fire some dojans!
Wait, what?
Oh, what are you doing over there?
Hello?
I've been waiting on the release of Bad Dreams on Mel Road.
Oh, well, good thing.
It's literally on the shelf right over there.
You could have just used your eyes.
Do you have rush hour on VHS?
I'm rushing, and the hours are going.
So yes.
Now you will love our movies.
You will love our movies.
No one will escape me.
Ha!
Am I in your way?
Oh, actually, I do need you to take this, though.
Uh-oh.
Wait, was that somebody at the cash register?
Oh, I dropped another one.
Why are you humphing at me?
And humphing and humphing.
Why are we like this, huh?
Don't be rude.
Oh, whatever.
Uh-oh, we have a little blockage.
Charge the fee.
Where did I throw that on the ground?
There.
Vushif!
No, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I like this game!
It's so like turn your brain off and just click, click, and
click.
Oh, it's perfect for a day like this.
Where I'm actually...
My brain is already off, you know what I mean?
Oops.
Sorry.
Roadblocks.
No, no, no.
Nice and comfy.
I hope you guys like it as much as I do.
I think this game is very charming.
Wow!
They only needed one night with the hot two rogues.
Okay, okay.
That will fly off the shelves.
Don't you worry.
This one though we can put in the back.
Head-empty, cozy games are fun.
Yeah.
Uh, yes.
Trying to steal my company secrets.
You'll never take me alive.
Because I'm already dead.
Drama.
What makes a drama movie like...
Is it just like seriousness?
Wow, though.
More or less.
I can't stop thinking of that guy that was like, my dad left
me.
I would like a drama.
I mean, you do you, man, but...
It's kind of crazy.
My ghost's only regret.
Hello.
It got Robert Pattinson and Zendaya.
Oh, yeah!
That's that new movie that came out.
I don't know anything about it
Lonely inmate Thank you for coming to purchase I'll pick it
up Good job You love movie You love movie You'll have a
better day with a movie Yeah This game turns your brain off
So watch I recently learned that How to expand the store
Yeah right like you literally just are like do things with
movie it's pretty fun though it's like one of those
addicting kind of games that you're just like oh I do the
thing make more money do the thing make money no don't leave
no no
yes no don't I'll get you I'll get you my sweet yes After I
chased you...
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
What's wrong?
How dare you accuse me of vandalism?
Take your money.
Yeah, I want to...
A whore... Why was she screaming at me like that?
You can get...
Officer Bloodbath.
Wow.
Oh, another raid.
Fear me!
Thank you for the raid!
That's the only choice.
Thank you, paperbacks.
Thank you, bring back.
Thank you, spank and I'm... Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Why is he just standing there?
Hi, Fee, boy.
Fee, boy, Fee, oh.
I'm running a very lucrative business here.
Hmm.
Oh.
Ooh.
This lady wants a movie.
You want a movie?
Hmm.
Oh, she's such a hater.
This guy wants a movie.
You want a movie?
Why is he looking at me like that?
Oh, a horror movie.
You can have the beast as yeah.
Wait, what was that one?
That deadly lady.
You can have the deadly lady.
Find it funny people still love love to try and find Waldo.
That's why I dress as him and visit random places.
Is that, if that, if you actually do that, that's kind of
crazy.
Hey.
Yeah?
Oh, I'm not talking to you.
Do you have a Christmas movie?
Wait, I don't care what season it is.
I'm always in a Christmas mood.
You can have the Wraith Christmas squad.
I also heard good things about it.
Do we have the Sussy Movie Man?
No.
Tomorrow though we have a new movie!
A release day!
Wait, I got some more achievements so I can have more money.
I don't think we'll get any new customers because it's
midnight.
Dang, we've been closing late every night, baby.
Bye, have a good one.
You are free to go.
I'll remember your faces.
This is the smallest bill I have.
What did you give?
What did you do to my Ryan?
Are you causing him grief and inconvenience?
Making the mood loud.
Oh, yeah.
Is your hair okay?
Hmm.
Yeah, you're the only one to blame.
Like, that looks painful.
It doesn't even look like her head is shaved.
It looks like she is, you know?
Like it just looks painful.
Christmas.
Let's just grab everything.
Reserved.
The dentist in good hands.
It doesn't sound like an adult movie.
Maybe that's why people get it.
They're like, oh, what's that movie you got there?
The dentist in good hands.
The boy with his treasure?
I don't want...
Oh, the bad boy.
Sorry.
The bad boy in his treasure.
Never seen that hairstyle?
What?
What is the hairstyle?
Like, I've seen a mohawk, but hers looks like...
Not a mohawk.
It looked like...
Like it was bloody.
Since it's Kohara's birthday...
Would you want to sing our elite student a birthday song?
If you want to, of course.
That's so true.
We should, right?
Liberty spikes.
Yeah, but no, it's not the spikes that hurt.
It's the fact that her head had a rash.
It's not the spike part.
It's the fact that her head was, like, bleeding.
I do dress as Waldo, and who knows, maybe you will spot me
at a car one day.
You could say you found Waldo.
I could, one day.
and greet as well though i miss koharu because i gave too
much to say yes
the rash is part of the cut okay guys we have to sing happy
birthday to my precious koharu baby my baby my baby she's my
baby my baby little koharu she's the baby my baby okay ready
ryan you will clock out once I'm done singing happy birthday
to my to my baby happy birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday Jill baby my baby co-haired you happy
birthday to you happy
Also, I did not read this as crime.
I read it as crimes.
I was like, we just have...
We just have a binder of our crimes.
Hidden here in the office.
It's not even quite hidden.
It's just...
Make sure to gift her a lot of doujin, she.
I will.
I will, I will.
Nah!
Level 10!
Oh my gosh, we got the clearance bin!
Wait, this is huge!
We can finally sell some of these things!
New movie, what did we get?
The Ultimate Space Saga Galactic Rebellion 4
Dobe Dobe
Alright, let's see.
Where can we put the clearance bin?
Nice.
Also you.
Who are you?
Uh, sign to return station.
Yeah, it's very good.
Oh.
My clearance.
Nice.
Maybe like right here.
You must pass by it to see the adult movies.
Now let's put some stuff in here.
All of these.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Whoa, there's so many movies can fit in here.
It's kind of crazy, actually.
Everybody wants the color violet.
Everybody wants it.
Don't let Disney see that poster!
Oh!
they wouldn't come after my humble shop they wouldn't
good job ryan i heard that it's disney hey at least it's not
nintendo
all right very nice 50% market value 50% off oh yeah Oh
yeah, oh yeah.
Do we have a lot of movies today, Ryan?
Seems like a good handful of them.
So true.
The desert on Christmas morning.
Wait, the desert or the dessert?
The desert.
What broke?
The demented ape.
Wait, I feel like...
So many movies are breaking recently.
Oh yeah, buy the new movie.
Thank you, thank you.
No!
Wait.
Oh, here.
We need to buy five copies or more.
I'll do you better.
I'll get ten copies.
These will all be in the clearance bin in a week.
Nice.
Not the Demented A.
Hello?
We're not open.
The fact that everybody walks around without umbrellas is so
funny to me.
Oh, N.R.
Standy.
The placement of the sticker?
Wait, I didn't see it.
He got Mike Wozowski's!
No!
Can I put this here?
Uh.
I want to keep it, but I don't know where to put it.
Why does he place them like this?
I think I'm going to get how many more.
A couple more maybe.
Nah.
That should be okay.
Static haunting.
My horror section is like...
Maybe I can move.
this you why why why hmm I guess 13 bodies can go probably
13 bodies has been around for a bit we can put static on
thing up but I think 13 bot well these are both classics
maybe you know everyone's big what Hello?
I was able to fit the other guy here.
Why not anymore?
What the heck?
Uh...
Let's see.
Move this over a little bit maybe.
Scoot...
There we go.
Very nice.
I'll put some of the...
poorer over here.
When we can.
go into the mixed I don't think it's bigger they're here
let's play if you dare alright we got a lot of movies left
come on Ryan we gotta get a move on look at how fast I'm
going look how I'm not wasting any time do you think I can
have Ryan handle adult movies Oh, whoops.
Or do you think, like, you...
Is it, like, alcohol where you have to be of an age to
handle the stuff?
Oh!
He only grabs, like, three at a time.
Oops.
He has a mustache.
You're right.
Wait, what was it?
Uh...
smoke at the velvet room we need more adult movies we don't
have enough maybe
uh market late night with my pixie static haunting poster
looks like absolute cinema that's a retirement with my hot
dog Two wheels, one medicine.
I thought it said.
The milk's true lover.
The bridge beyond the hag.
The android walks alone.
Quiet time with the ghost.
Quiet time with the cash.
Two brothers.
Wait!
No way!
We had a bad dreams on Melro get broken.
That sucks, actually.
I'm not firing you.
Check out.
Because that's a new release.
No, that sucks.
Dang, that's a lot of customers.
It's a lot of people saying o's and o's.
It's a lot of o's and o's.
But I'm hearing.
Oh,
cowboy.
You love movies.
No, you don't.
You don't love anything.
Maybe.
Oh.
Oh,
he got his little baggy.
He's ready to enjoy some fine cinema.
The desert.
Five for five.
That's five big ooze!
Ooh!
What'd you get?
She's like, I'll never tell.
I'll never tell.
No.
That's so sad.
Now the ghost has two regrets.
I wonder if we make money off the popcorn.
Oh, which one's this one?
Sheep.
Oh, this was your Lion April.
That's right.
Oh, yeah, we do have Diskeel.
We'll see if she ever comes back to us.
Okay.
Table for two with RTRX.
Yes?
The dentist is in good hands, you little freak.
There you go.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Hmm.
I love living in a town that has no shame.
Oh.
Wait, don't leave.
Don't leave.
Hmm.
What about you?
No?
It's a gloomy, gloomy day, though.
People should be wanting to stay home and watch movies, no?
The weather sucks.
Maybe you want to...
Yeah, you want to stay home and...
Dragon poppers.
Lemon tea!
Thank you so much for the pink!
Sorry for not watching your stream frequently.
Having a job really messed up by Vito's schedule.
I don't want to apologize at all!
I hope you'll enjoy a cup of tea for yourself more in my
boat!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
I hope work's going well for you.
Ooh.
If you ever want to watch Minto, Vah, it's always available.
No worries at all.
Oh, Klein is asking to see the manager.
Why?
My tape got stuck in my VCRs, the machine's fault.
Ugh.
Yeah, you will go to another place next time.
I don't want you eating my tapes.
She probably ate the ghost's regret.
I bet you, I bet you, I bet you.
Are you coming over?
No?
Did you say humph?
Did you say humph to that?
Alright.
Everybody hates my business.
I've got to go out of business.
Hey!
I ain't gonna survive these.
Sorry, I didn't know who I was talking to.
some skew thank you let's see what we got let's see what we
got
marrying my hot dog it's 50 bucks but it's shiny we'll buy
it
grandma's lady pie that one is a little expensive so well
A ghost, a Christmas legend!
Absolutely.
All I need is my infection.
Thank you for the movies.
Thank you, thank you.
Retirement.
Oh, I forgot I bought this.
Retirement with my hot dog.
Marrying my hot...
Actually, it's time.
Marrying my hot dog.
dog.
Display four holographic movies in a display case.
I got an achievement.
Wait, that means more money.
Dreamed of bad movies on Oh, here we go.
Ooh.
Wait, I could have sworn I heard a lady's voice.
But he just had the ooh.
Do you think our store is haunted?
Maybe?
Oh.
Wait, why are we closing at 8 p.m.?
Is it because it's Sunday?
What else do we get?
Unlock all store expansions.
Buy an arcade machine.
Own 500 movies.
Own 1,000 movies.
Hire two employees.
Sell 20 cotton candies.
Sell 20 popcorns.
Generate $10,000 in total revenue.
Surely we're close to that, right?
Hello.
An old movie.
Just old?
Yeah, look, the sun's not even down yet.
More closing.
The devs announced today that a video game rental update is
in the works.
No way!
I'm glad that they're still updating this game so much.
How fun!
Oh, reserved.
Explosive Zilla.
Okay.
These are a bit expensive, but some are adult skews to
consider.
No!
Wait, sorry for the last one.
Oh, okay.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Wait, hold on.
What do you mean by sorry?
What do you mean by that?
You caught my mushroom!
Wait, that one's pretty good.
I'll buy it.
goldfish action.
That's disgusting.
Oregon in my mouth!
And the last one.
I kind of want to get it because I need to know who will buy
it.
Three and a half stars.
Yeah, what does it mean by old?
not even not not even with the family excuse
we're gonna get some real freak azoids in my shop now guys
some real hooligans
i saw that ace combat a dove diary trailer where dove
mentioned they took around 1000 pics of the uss worded 3d
scanning the ship looks so good in game engine too thank you
game Yeah!
This is dogs and dinos after all.
For the ghosties out there?
Oh, thank you, X-Ray.
Wait, give me a second.
Give me a second.
Oh, my gosh.
I hate how they all...
You pick them up, and no matter how you pick them up, they
all get scrambled in your hands.
Let's see.
In bed with the ghost!
list i
think we must all right oh uh what's today oh it's sunday we
will wait until tuesday have a good night ryan valid
purchase thank you oh wait did we make any money from the
clearance bin i did not check oh my gosh we sold a couple
movies.
I told you everybody wanted the color of Iowa.
Yeah.
Oh, fresh-shaven Ryan.
Returns are piling up already today.
That's what you said yesterday too.
This is how it is every morning, Ryan.
This is how it is every morning.
He's like, don't talk to me until I'm getting paid first.
Oh, Whoops, no, no, I check out.
Return station.
JPEG dog finally has evolved into a real dog.
No!
Oh, he's been JPEG dog.
It is pretty good.
Let's see.
Do I have the ceiling sign?
I do, but let's get another one.
Let's get some decorations up in here.
Some baloo...
Oh, wait.
Let's do...
What else will we be?
Let's do a small neon sign.
A neon sign.
Okay, okay.
I got a couple decoration things.
Oh, we got a big old star.
That can go right here.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's such a good decoration.
Let me reserve and bed with the ghost, please.
Sorry, it's already reserved.
Sorry, so sorry.
Wait, did we get the same one as before?
Yes, we did.
Lame.
That's fine.
We're decorating.
And I got the same one as before.
You know what?
That's fine, too, though.
Oh, yeah.
You can change them.
Wait, you can?
How?
Doesn't seem like I can.
You can customize it.
Oh my god!
Yay!
Oh, this will make people want the popcorn.
I thought Derek, you just got what you got!
Oh my god!
No, let's go!
Ooh, ooh, pause here.
Oh yeah.
Wait, oh these ones too maybe.
Okay, we can move this one then.
We can move this one like...
Here, we can change it to...
We'll change it to the star.
Oh!
Oh, it's too good!
Oh, it's too good.
Oh my god, it's perfect.
It's poifect even.
Oh, yes!
Oh, yes.
I'm so happy.
Alright, what else are we doing?
We got many returns.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, he's coming back.
He's gonna get mad at me.
Hold on.
My hands are full.
Science fiction.
Oh, no.
It's the new movie.
Oops.
They're all over the place.
He has no sense of organization.
You know?
He just throws them where he wants to throw them.
I'll do like that.
The XXX really stands out.
It means hugs and kisses.
XO, XO.
Gossip Girl.
Okay, I could go, like, really way faster.
Okay, here we go.
Watch this.
They don't call me the boss for nothing.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
All right, Christmas.
Action, action.
The cougar wants my fairy.
Of course she does.
Romance?
Who ordered the hot T-Rex?
The day that that breaks, if it ever does, will be actually
so sad.
I think I might cry.
It's like our bestseller.
Bad dreams on Melra.
Good job.
Good job calling it in before...
before it all sells out check out all right here we go
everybody another day another dollar why do they sound so
upset when you like give them one of these you know they're
so like you didn't have to accept the flyer you could have
said No.
Waldo is back.
Oh, I don't have any more.
Oops.
Thought I had more flyers.
Yes.
Explosive Zilla.
There you go.
Hmm.
Wow.
And then there's such haters when you do give them a flyer,
when they were literally standing outside.
Oh, are you okay?
Okay.
Bad dreams!
Oh, it's not a bad movie!
Sorry, I said the wrong thing.
Oh, he's fine now.
They sound so ungrateful.
Oh, Waldo!
Bye.
I wonder what he got.
Do I have a copy?
Ooh, you came.
Oh.
Yeah, there you go.
They're selling like hotcakes.
Um, um.
And so was our clearance section.
everybody did you see that we have one galactic rebellion
why is the flyer grand opening because we just opened like
three months ago we're basically babies we just opened why
is everyone such a hater please you want the movie Yeah, she
wants me.
And by me, I mean a movie.
Actually, I don't even, I think it was like a month ago that
we opened.
Right?
Thank you for your business.
I will never come back here!
Don't take it personally.
I think he's taking it personally.
I think...
This guy tried to rent two things of Bad Dreams on Melrose.
This guy sucks.
I was returning a late movie.
Since I'm calling ahead, is there any chance you could wave
the fee?
No.
Hey?
Oh, you wanted popcorn.
Ah.
He needs some thicker skin.
I think he's okay.
Bye for Ryan.
You are so sad.
Reserved.
The chosen hag.
Wait, is that going to be a hot movie?
Is that going to be a hot movie?
Okay.
Everybody say, everybody give Ryan some encouragement.
Wait, we have so much of the static haunting.
We can put these in the clearance bin.
We only need one.
Oh, this is a adult movie.
Science fiction, science fiction, dentist in good hands.
La la la la la.
Drama, drama, drama.
Um, um.
One moment, please.
Scary sailor.
And then this is for sale.
Look, things are really selling!
It's kind of crazy.
A romance.
I found a box of love letters from my ex and made me
reminisce.
Aww.
You can get...
Tango.
Fairy between our hearts.
It's very great.
It's a rite of passage, Ryan.
I know.
Poor guy.
He's like, I'm just doing my job.
my boss will fire me otherwise I wouldn't I wouldn't fire
but I would like him to collect late fees yeah that's true
we'll get this guy in a second oh yeah Ryan I give you
permission to kill if someone is being mean oh dr. Lane's
chosen hag yes of course yes great taste
good job Ryan oh awesome the hot dog body snatchers oh
fellow connoisseur wait look at all these potential
customers I'm about to lose.
Nice.
You want a movie.
You know you do.
Why were you staring at my billboard then?
Wow.
With such lust in your eyes.
You looked at that and you were like, that sounds great.
Don't deny your body what you want.
What you crave.
What you need.
This client has to see a manager.
What?
Why?
Oh.
What did he get the?
Yeah, the hag.
No.
I don't want your business if you're going to break my
stuff.
We just got that movie.
Also, uh-oh.
Is it going to come back broken?
I hope not.
Hello.
Yes.
There you go.
Oh.
my mind's telling me no but my body is telling me yes these
guys always complain when they break tapes it's disgusting
it really is like they don't take any responsibility for
their actions no accountability just say you're sorry and
and and just take accountability Hmm.
Oh, that's a buy one?
I don't know what you want me to say, lady.
Oh, tobacco in my mouth.
Nice.
We got a nice, healthy little stock of movies here, don't
we?
And tomorrow is the guy.
Life lessons from Guru Phantom.
Hmm.
Rules are rules.
Yeah, you were late and that's the rule.
Does that mean someone else couldn't rent your movie?
Hey.
Kissing my organ in the sky?
Is that a romance?
What the hell are we selling here?
See ya.
What'd you get?
Wait, it was too fast.
Sausage in Miami!
The vengeful ghost.
Nice chores.
I'm trying to rearrange this a little bit.
Uh...
Let's do...
Like the...
Oh nice.
Perfect amount.
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
My arms can't reach.
We could fill this up with more movies.
Honestly, I think I want to get more of the Galactic guys.
But I don't want the poster.
But I want to save the bunny, you know?
I don't want the sandy.
Gorgo!
Welcome to Bambusha!
Thank you!
You can sell the poster for 10 bucks.
Oh, okay, perfect.
Thank you.
Let's get a couple more of these.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I was like, where did these come from?
Duh, I just bought them.
Bozo.
And then...
We'll sell this bad boy.
Nice.
And...
Yeah.
That should be good.
One second.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
You good?
We're good?
We're good.
We're not making so much more money, though.
Our movie is rented in return.
Just still, I feel quite low.
Request a Habanera Muppet for next karaoke.
Indy!
I don't think I will remember.
You can request...
What is Remembrance Day?
Oh my god, we just have graves out here.
What is today?
What is this day?
A day where many watching moving films that honor the past.
Okay.
We have lots of dramas.
We do have lots of dramas.
Good morning, boss.
Good morning, Ryder.
It's me, the tape dealer.
I robbed a house last night.
And found a few movies I think you'd like.
I'll drop them off in your store's back drop box.
Thanks.
What do you think I'll like?
The lonely singer?
The bun's wrong number?
A cozy biscuit holiday?
For the werewolf?
And Gambler Cyberlink.
Okay, tape dealer.
I thought we had a deal on what kind of movies you would be
supplying me.
You know, you catch my drift?
Not your best work, deal.
That's what I'm saying.
She's handing us off the trash.
I mean, to be fair.
Oh, my Tamagotchi is dead.
How?
Wait, was I supposed to... Oh, is it live again?
I robbed a house last night.
To be fair, you didn't buy the stolen property.
Yeah, that's what I'm seeing.
Yeah, that's what I was about to say.
It was a donation, so...
You know, I don't know.
Beggars can't be choosers, right?
Looks like we're gonna be getting some fantasy films soon.
That's exciting.
Um, we get a refrigerator?
Of 14.
Wait, I want orc invaders.
A lot of Christmas skews.
Oh, thank you, Paige.
I don't know if I needed Christmas.
Let's see though.
Santa's spirit is coming to town.
The hot dog waiting for Santa.
I won't get so many because I think a fast food, a holiday
spark.
Because I don't think I have so much room for them.
The hot dog of Christmas legend.
The ghost's Christmas sock.
I have to buy that one too.
These all sound so good.
The little reindeer's dragon.
That one's kind of expensive.
The snowman's heart.
Thank you very much for All of these
Some more adult movie skews
Why is this game obsessed with hot dog movies?
It's not.
It's that we are catering to a hot dog crowd
Dripping on the biscuit is something.
His massive buffalo
Sweaty wolf I hate that the...
That the...
What's it called?
They're so expensive.
The adult movies, you know.
Hi there.
I'll take over here now.
Let me just handle these right quick.
Yeah, our new releases.
Oh, he's doing a good job.
Oh, he didn't do such a bad job now.
Okay.
We'll take it.
What broke?
Wait, no, this is...
The saucy snake delivery!
Wait, what is on the back?
Mushroom.
What is that is not rated PG?
No!
Alright, just go back to checkout.
I'll do the rest.
I'm so sad.
Can't believe we lost a snake movie.
Wait, what was that?
Dr. Lane's chosen relic!
Oh, wait, no, that's something else I was thinking.
I thought that I was thinking of the chosen hag.
People rewinding and pausing the adults.
movies oh gosh we're running out we're running out of space
we're gonna have to get more we're gonna have to get bigger
and bigger shelving i think oh wait a second i forgot that
you can sell stuff so honestly i feel like i should sell a
bunch of stuff and then just get like big big big you know
uh shelving hmm What'd you drop here?
The dessert on Christmas morning.
Yeah, upgrades.
Okay.
If I take this and if I sell it, what happens to all the
stuff on it?
Yeah, I might need aisles.
That's what I'm thinking too.
Alright, we're gonna do a little bit...
Before we open, we're gonna do a little bit of rearranging.
I'm gonna try selling it.
I'm scared.
Oh, it must be empty.
Okay, good.
Alright, all the small shelves...
All small shelves must go.
We are too big for small shelves anymore.
Just the random adult movie.
So funny.
Yeah, we're upsizing.
Movies are in high, high demand now.
It's time.
We're like big, big shelves like this action one, you know?
Horror.
Especially for horror.
My goodness.
Yeah, we're big time.
now oh yeah the big the great upgrades that people have
probably been hoping for begging for they're here baby
they're here oh i have to replenish my snacks even i haven't
done that in a minute maybe maybe we could put it like here
so that they get it on their way out now this is looking
very liminal space because like the random smileys
I'm investing everything into this.
Everything, everything, everything.
So far, our adult section is great.
We don't need a bigger thing.
I'm even gonna sell these medium ones, honestly.
Like these mid-size ones.
Actually, hold on.
I'm gonna put them away.
Because we might need, we might need, like, if I don't have
the money to buy a bunch, you know what I mean?
Okay.
Sounds good.
Yeah, the industry will never change.
I mean, this...
We can't imagine how far...
Like, this is the greatest technology we'll ever be!
Oops.
I did the wrong one again.
I always press the wrong button.
Okay.
Alright.
And you.
Oh yeah.
Okay!
All right.
Very good.
Now...
Oh, I did it again.
You.
All right, let's do some rows now.
We'll take even this.
Yes.
Very good.
And I didn't need to customize you.
Yes.
Yes, okay.
Because these ones are expensive, no?
225?
Oh, wait.
210?
Three.
Holy cow.
I could only afford three.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
I mean, we still want some things on the wall, so maybe I
can put my smaller...
Actually, I'm thinking the big shell.
should be along the wall and then the small ones should be
in the aisles let's maybe that's better that would probably
be more aesthetically pleasing because nobody one thing that
i hate is going to a place and i can't see over the over the
shells yeah make it feel less crowded exactly exactly
exactly you guys are feeling the vibes hello Is it because
of all these?
At least I know.
Isn't that most places for you?
Yes, that's why I don't like it.
Get the hit.
There we go.
That should be good.
Just a few more.
There we go.
People are going to come in and be like, Oh, good.
I can't wait to go over to my designated drama section right
over here.
Wait, did I have...
Oh no, they're just the same one.
Or they have the same cover.
The whole movie place...
The whole store has been rearranged.
That would drive me bonkers.
Wait, why can't I place it anymore?
Weird.
Oh, because of the star?
Really?
Wait.
Oh, you're so right.
That was weird.
okay let's go get these
I will put this one here because I think it skinny is all
that will fit here yeah yeah yeah that's okay that's okay
though and then we start
they're different sizes wait wait how big are you are you
the same size wait why are they different size oh my gosh I
think One is a four shelf and one is a five shelf.
No, stinking.
One, two, three, four.
My store is ugly!
We can order another one of these.
It's all ruined.
It's all gone to hell.
Uh, floor shelf.
Right?
Oh, because I had the thin one before.
That's why.
Okay.
Wait.
What are... Who are you?
Oh!
I got another big one.
Okay.
Actually, I'm not gonna have these this way.
I'm gonna...
We're gonna have these.
this way.
We're mixing it up, baby.
We gotta change you.
Yeah, now they match.
Alright.
Let's stock this with some Crunchzilla.
And, uh...
Um...
What was our, like, cost?
Yeah, like, the chips instead.
off are like super what the hell is that disco com god the
let's get some freddy cheese sticks
and uh dino gummies we have to get the dino gummies
obviously yeah they're so on brand yeah that's what oh uh I
hope it's okay.
Wait, I can't get those movies.
Uh-oh.
That's fine, maybe.
Uh.
I think it's okay.
Those are lost forever.
No!
Decoration.
Yeah, it's giving, like, it's supposed to be, like, you
know, Oh!
Um, stuff under the bed!
Oh, nice.
They exploded?
Okay, this will be our sci-fi area.
I'm trying not to make it too different because then...
I'll also forget where things were, you know what I mean?
So...
Green...
And green.
Nice.
And...
Actually, this is like so...
This is so Star Wars.
I mean, sorry.
So, Galactic Rebellion.
Do I have enough?
To, like, have individual shells now?
I don't know if I do.
Like, I
don't know if I do.
That's okay.
We'll be able to buy more, eventually.
Okay.
Wow.
That's cool.
Like, action.
We'll put our dramas here.
Because we have a ton of these.
And they'll definitely want to use that shelf as well.
I think.
Probably.
My brain is too smooth for this right now.
I dropped it anyway.
Let's see.
Okay.
That's good.
So
we still have a romance?
Okay.
I think we just have romance and Christmas, don't we?
So if we can...
Take these.
Put them over in the sci-fi.
Yeah.
This is an action.
Oh, but...
Okay, hold on.
Let's keep drama.
Oh no, I think we still have not even enough...
for the drama still.
Oh my gosh.
We definitely don't have enough for drama.
We don't have enough for horror.
So let's do this.
This can be a Christmas.
This can be a romance.
Action.
Oh my goodness.
My spaghetti hands.
I mean, spaghetti, no.
Butterfinger, sorry.
My hands.
are spaghetti.
Okay, this is Christmas.
Okay.
Or...
And then I could just buy two more of these for the extra...
to, like, make another aisle kind of thing.
Can I afford?
Four.
I can't!
No!
Oops, I forgot some Christmas.
Just holding on to them.
Um.
Huh.
My guy's standing at the register like, bro, how is it still
8 AM?
This is how it really feels, working a job, huh?
Um.
Okay.
We'll just have these on the ground.
Actually, no.
We'll just mix some stuff up until we're able to uh until
we're able to afford it.
So romance will be our mixed area.
Christmas is red.
Action.
I think we chose yellow but I feel like blue just looks
better.
Like that.
Um this is romance.
And we'll make it playful.
like that and horror
like that drama sci-fi
we'll make it blue okay
yeah I've seen the storage yeah it's okay but I would rather
have more movies like this part I would rather have just
more movies out and about.
I don't see if there, I don't know if there's like a
downside to having, you know.
But now we have at least a little bit more space.
So, all right, let's start the day and make some money.
And then along the way I can, uh, along the way I can, um,
just buy new shelves.
Oh, okay.
That's a lot of people coming in.
Besides you, you stinking hater.
What the heck?
Oh my god.
Did he...
Did he have...
Did he have Tic-Tac-Toe tattooed on him?
Let me play.
Oh.
You look friendly.
Why are we humping?
All right.
Very good, everybody.
Very...
Oh.
I have another sign.
I have another thing.
Now we can deco... Wait.
No, this one is...
Whoa!
Whoa.
What if we did everything like this?
Wait.
Whoa.
Oh, my eyes.
I've been struggling to get the motivation to study for
finals.
Definitely pushing what I can cram.
Can I get a call to action?
Just another guy.
You are not just another guy.
You are the most capable guy.
And you're going to ace your exams.
But the only way you can ace them is if you study, study,
study.
And if you don't study, I will end stream right now.
An old movie.
There you go.
What does your tattoo say?
Baddy?
What does it say?
He's got...
What does it say on it?
Oh, bad boy!
You got jaws?
You got aliens?
He likes my little pony?
Is that...
What is that?
Oh, it's a gesture.
Yeah, you better study and you...
Someone got the chips!
Nice.
Alright, we already have more money.
Yeah.
Awesome, right?
I know.
Hmm.
No.
No whom.
What about you?
Nice.
Thank you very much.
Science fiction.
Oh, nice.
Dr. Lanzius, chosen relic.
Yes, I chose it myself.
You can put posters on the outside of windows.
You can?
No way!
Like this?
Wait, I can change the skill too!
Neo Uncle Assault.
My money at school.
Wait, I'll...
I want it to be...
The Ghost Test!
We'll choose that for now.
Wait, but if I do this...
No.
What do you want?
Galactic Rebellion?
This one?
what's a good skill get our gun down thank you so much
welcome to membership it's gotta be oh
don't leave don't leave don't leave don't leave don't leave
I like how only half of my stores decorated like this what
have I been doing doing now I'm like so invested in my store
I think at first I was like yeah whatever and now I'm like
no it's got to be a great store you know what I mean what's
the skew for till women do us part yeah yeah yeah a bat oh
my god why is she slow turned looking at me like that I want
to prank my partner and rent a bad movie he's going to lose
it give me your worst movie I'd recommend your record or I'd
enjoy your recommendation even more if you give me a
Christmas film.
Sorry.
A bad, bad, bad little reindeer's teacher.
Here you go.
Could I do the honors of painting your video store?
I won't spill any.
You are, you are, uh, what's the word?
You have expertise, so yes, you may, you may.
Let's go get some more shelves.
Oh my god, we're gonna have actual rows now, you guys.
We're gonna have actual rows.
This is huge.
Wait, that?
That seems, yeah.
You da-bush, man.
Thanks, Jacob!
Thank you for almost two years, holy cow.
Hey.
Welcome to MemboShap.
Thank you!
Bad dreams on Mel Road.
Oh, I do actually.
You're welcome.
We'll do horror.
And we'll do... what was the other one?
Drama?
Or action?
We'll do action instead.
This one.
I heard him knocking on my door.
I want to see it happen.
Hello, mister.
I sell bootleg movies, but the quality is impeccable, I
swear.
Convict in my mouth.
A bestseller in the underground market.
Dead flower in the attic.
It's cheap.
Frying pan in the velvet room.
Clairvoyant nutcrackers.
This one's not on adult film.
His werewolf is too big.
Spicy choice.
Holy cow.
Oh whoops.
His werewolf's too big.
That's crazy.
That's crazy!
Still says, oh, this way.
Drama.
Now it's all romance.
Yay!
We don't have any more mixed anymore, except that one, but
it's because it's free.
Yay!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, hello.
A good movie.
There you go.
Are you able to change the design of the brochures?
Oh, I don't know.
Can you?
No, it doesn't look like it.
Like the flyers, you mean?
He's got too much dog on him.
Is that even possible to have too much dog in you?
Are you a slow walker asking for a mo-mo?
A little mo- what mo-mo is asking, huh?
I actually think I'm of...
faster walker than most because i am used to being around
such fast walkers that i have like adopted the fast walk you
know what i mean wow we can even change these the
customization goes crazy let's do purple
yes yes some more purple yes even down here holy cow
what else can i customize
wait oh no that's just the floor in general wait i kind of
like this one too that's kind of cute reminds me of a
bedroom howdy mean though getting sleepy so i'm heading to
bed good night hope your video story remains successful and
no newfangled technology comes along that makes it obsolete.
That could never, ever, ever, ever, ever in a million years
ever happen.
Well, thank you for your concern.
I'll take it.
I'll take it into consideration, you know?
Oh, fantasy!
Well, I guess we have, uh, instead of action there, we'll do
some fantasy.
Maybe.
we got oh wait oh i have to order them
yes yes oh my bad there we go took a while to get fantasy
yeah right let's see what we got the queen of the zombie the
wishmakers clairvoyant quest for the holy race car Tomb of
the Curse Spirit!
Wait, that's so good.
The Loaf Spellcaster.
Echoes of the Burning Bubblegum.
These don't seem very fantasy.
The Trophy Summoning Spell.
Dark Sailor Magic.
The Quest for the Holy Milk Carton.
A Knight's Path to his Ghost.
Wait, that sounds romantic.
Fantasy.
Actually, I will make this one green.
Oh, no, green is.
We'll make this one brown.
Brown, yeah, brown.
One year, I mean to membership.
Thank you, robot.
Thank you so much.
Nice.
Well, we don't have so much fantasy right now, but of course
we'll need it eventually.
I'm wondering if I should...
We're going to commit to the purple.
Okay.
Actually.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
We're gonna commit to it.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, yeah.
This is fine.
Maybe.
Yes.
Commit.
Commit to it.
This is...
Dinos and Dinos.
I can't remember the...
Actually, maybe I should make it like...
If I could make it like a...
What's the word?
Like a...
Green and red and yellow.
Like a hot dog and a dinosaur.
Hi Minky.
Hi Tuna!
A few years I'll come out with the audio company, the flip
books.
They'll never need to be rewinded.
They'll just turn to page one.
Wait, Tuna, is your two-year deck, y'all?
Nashi.
Thank you for the pink.
Wait, our store looks brand new.
What's going on over here?
Are you sick?
You look fine.
This is awkward, but I think I deserve a $14 raise.
I think it's like 14 in the day right now he gets paid can I
leave I don't I he makes like 30 something dollars a day I'm
pretty sure thank him okay but at the same time I make like
300 dollars a day so
it's not that I'm trying to underpay the guy or anything but
What?
I need to...
A ghost needs to eat too.
For Ryan, you can keep the change.
Sweet.
I don't even get a thank you.
How much?
Fifty-three dollars a day!
Wait a second.
He has so many traits, though, which makes him good, you
know?
But holy cow!
Regarding your limbo, the last tweet, that game is held to
run to the point that Mandalore Gaming had to reinstall his
entire OS.
That's crazy.
As a concerned parent, I'm calling to make a suggestion.
Could you promote healthier snacks in your store?
Not my problem.
What are you talking about?
We have Crunchzilla and Dino Gummies.
Freddy Cheese Snicks.
Cheese is calcium.
I don't want to hear it.
I don't need some helicopter mom coming up in here saying,
Oh, my Johnny deserves pretzels.
I mean, carrots.
Ma'am, I'm not a grocery store.
But you know what?
Slaps?
Okay, wait.
Actually, I'm going to say, I'm going to ask this.
Are pirates booty?
Is that considered a healthy snack?
I don't consider it one.
I don't care about your opinion.
Kind of.
No, but they're good.
They're so yummy, though.
You ask?
They're far better than some of the alternatives, I guess.
Yeah, that's what I mean.
So, comparatively speaking, Pirate's booty is all great,
healthy.
You can't convince me otherwise.
It's delicious and healthy and nutritious.
Okay, maybe nutritious is going a little bit far.
yummy
we can get the armor and the banner I like the banner look
at that at least we can put that because it's on like a
small shelf only right now we can put that kind of like
right here you know as a decoration oh good oh good
yeah yummy definitely yummy yeah yummy yummy yummy yummy
yummy yummy yummy yummy yummy all right you're gonna work
real actually now can I tell you work faster I can step it
up a notch yeah exactly I you got a raise buddy so I want to
see you going crazy hard oh I forgot to I just remembered I
forgot to shoot Oops.
I forgot to.
Oops.
We're fine.
It's all good.
Excuse me.
Nice.
Don't return stuff.
I'm working on it.
No, don't return stuff yet!
I'm scared!
Oh nice, we're getting all these back.
Um, um, hold your horses, lady.
Thank you.
Thank you for your... Yes?
Galactic Rebellion.
There you go.
Did you rewind them all?
These people have been great.
They've been rewinding them.
We're in good hands.
Dang, we have so much sci-fi.
It's kind of insane.
Why is sci-fi getting booked like crazy right now?
Oops, you go there.
There we go.
Sci-fi.
Yes, okay.
Yes, Christmas.
It's our Christmas.
My top three TCG.
Yu-Gi-Oh, Dual Masters, Chaotic.
I don't know Chaotic.
Of course no Yu-Gi-Oh and Dual Masters.
Actually, when I was in Japan, when I was in Japan, Atore...
Pink neon cowboy.
Was doing a...
Atore is like a store.
Like usually connected to...
Usually connected to like a train station.
looks like it's a department store and the one in Akiba
always has like a collaboration and their collaboration was
Yu-Gi-Oh aww oh no
nightmare on Mill Street is not new anymore okay into the
clearance bin it goes broken no alright let's go put these
all in the horror what second one second you can go in the
clearance bad boy with this treasure yes we got it despise
it despise it didn't know he could break it I know people
suck oh sorry are you waiting for me what do you want what
did you need oh when's second I'll put this on the dramas of
romance I saw an old photo of my first love today ah you
deserve our plant pots first date yep yeah don't make it
happen again don't let it happen again I'll just keep
milking your money baby sausage in Miami wait sausage in
Miami is not an adult film you're killing you kidding me
right now you're pulling my leg what else would it be hmm
all right we're just gonna be pulling all the genres now one
moment ma'am I will be right with you please hold your
horses
Drama.
Sci-fi.
Horror.
This one will go into the...
Jorabma.
Okay.
Satan and his alien.
There you go.
Wow.
So many horses in this video store.
How is everybody enjoying our upgraded shop?
beautiful is it not everyone some people are going to be
like oh my gosh I love this movie so much I was wishing I
could buy it and now they're going to be able to buy it
actually the movies for sale kind of seems a little like
kind of seems lucrative no look so clean and professional I
would shop here yeah you would shop till you drop here baby
I know you're the type you're the type
Oh, I...
Oh!
We have horses, and everything else in between.
This guy wants to see a manager.
Oh, yeah, bad boy in his treasure.
Enjoy.
What's wrong?
Maybe the movie I returned broke when I dropped it in the
drop box.
This is unfair.
Yeah, we got
Oh wow, lots of stuff being dropped.
Oh my goodness.
So many things getting dropped.
Oh.
Hey up, Bozo.
That's exactly what I said.
I have great customers.
Oh, look, see, see me.
People are buying.
Nice.
The officer.
The only Shinova.
why are like movies like that so funny like the last samurai
looking for a fantasy movie but not the typical princess in
distress tale where the knight saves everyone it's always
the same story alright Sandrine let's give you the quest for
the holy race car this is not your typical fantasy story be
kind 2, 3, 1!
Back up, lady.
Sandrine's a little freaky.
We know this of her.
This is like nothing new.
Cup overdrive.
Yeah!
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Bye, bye, bye.
Oh, it's Wednesday.
Wait, did I get any more achievements?
I can't remember.
No.
I suck at this game.
I'm just kidding.
All right.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
In fact, since we do have more space on our shelves, I will.
Oh, I was going to say I will buy like 10 random movies,
but...
Maybe tomorrow.
Love between machine...
Wait, the machine between love.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
The breakup over the doll.
That's a voodoo doll.
Holy cow.
Lord, and thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Scary breakfast flick.
I'm kind of hungry.
I haven't...
Well, the dinner that I tried to have was too spicy for me.
So I didn't really have dinner.
Nice gifts.
Nice, nice.
Close the door.
We'll do one more day.
Spooky season!
Oh, they're so cute!
Oh, my god.
Oh, they're so cute.
Oh.
Wow.
Spooky season.
Everybody wants to get Halloween movie.
Where is...
Oh.
Oh!
I'm ready to push the movies today.
That's the spirit.
Wait, I just realized this is like not up against the wall.
There we go.
Okay, that's better.
Yes?
Employee jump scare?
Can you handle the return station, please?
Thank you.
Let's get some more movies.
10 random movies, bye!
What the heck?
Or no way, they're all Christmas movies.
Did I accidentally buy a Christmas one?
Okay, I did not realize.
Giving my toadstool for Christmas.
Oh, I did.
Now, Santa's favorite sausage.
It was worth it?
Hot chocolate fairy.
Oh, that sounds good.
I'm gonna miss...
I was gonna say I was gonna get some bubble tea after this,
but I just realized it's closed.
It just closed.
No!
It's so spooky.
here so scary wait okay i definitely can't buy another
expansion but that's okay we're still buying other things we
need to get to level 14 for the refrigerator hello fairy
between our hearts of course of course of course i'm loving
the makeup i'm loving the mask ryan thank you for being so
stuff.
I love it.
I'm loving it.
Well, I guess having more Christmas is not bad, but
hopefully we have enough room for it.
I'll help out too.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah.
What's your go-to Bobo recommendation?
I really just like a basic milk tea.
But, oh my gosh!
Gong Cha recently has had such a delicious strawberry almond
milk drink that I'm obsessed with.
Oh my gosh, I got it.
I got it last time I was in Japan and I got it the time
before that.
No shop is closed if you have a crowbar and a brick.
So true.
Okay, I'm gonna...
one big one big big boy
or we can buy uh another this is sitting way too close or we
can buy another pair of shells you know
almond I'm obsessed recently I don't know it's not that I am
drinking a lot of almond milk but Somehow it's ended up that
I've been drinking almond milk.
Like my orders have all been almond milk for some reason.
Oh, wait, there we go.
We'll put this in the corner.
Kind of like that, right?
It doesn't match the romance.
Actually...
Can I put it there?
Like that?
I wish I could put this on top of something.
It's kind of like in the way.
We'll just...
Wait, no!
I can't sell it.
It's spooky time right now.
Literally in this very moment.
Romance is spooky.
So true.
Oat milk is the goat, though.
I agree.
As the truest oatmeal connoisseur.
I love.
I...
I can't find any empty action or mixed shelves.
Oh no.
What are you gonna do with it?
Oh, okay.
Good job.
Sounds like we need to get two more shelves.
sounds like it yeah nice job ryan i'm a rice milk boy oat
milk horchata sounds amazing horchata fit fat gamers welcome
to membership thank you i love oat milk i will yeah oat milk
is so freaking tasty.
I hate that.
When I go to move it, it, like, changes the direction.
Why?
Stop doing that.
What?
Oh.
You're fine.
Don't worry about it, buddy.
We'll take care of it.
We'll take care of it in a bit.
Oh, he's, like, stuck in...
Okay, here.
Go back to checkout.
He's stuck in...
He's...
He has no purpose in his sad little life.
Trofage summoning spell.
Got you.
Okay.
What got broken?
The keyboard blast off.
Oh, wait.
We have something else got returned, though.
Wait, that's so strange.
Why did...
Oh, maybe he was too busy, like, trying to put away the
action movie.
Okay.
have enough room for two more now whoo spooky
which means we can get like more action like what's nice is
you can get even more movies like once you i guess that's
kind of the point when you have more shelves you can get
more movies but you know what i mean
okay this will be action actually
no this will be it's kind of stupid but hear me out this
will be more fantasy because they're facing each other you
know wait are they two different colors yes and then this
will be the action one oh I changed action to blue actually
we'll go back to yellow we'll go back to yellow because we
don't have anything else that's yellow right now okay
can I buy any more fantasy just to put it on there yeah bye
oh fantasy bye Bye.
Okay, that one was kind of explained.
Wait, what was this last one?
The mushroom.
A dead shroom in the attic.
No, too scary.
Wait!
Fantasy is kind of yellow.
Maybe we change it.
Maybe we change fantasy to yellow.
Okay, we'll change it.
Yellow.
Blue.
blue okay look at that we have actual shelves we're gonna
have rows soon you guys this is crazy hot dog indeed
why is nobody else oh you were dressed up oops sorry I think
I threw something at someone
we have a phone call really enjoying you playing this game I
I literally cannot stop watching.
I'm glad you like a biz!
Did you promote healthier snacks?
Not my problem.
Go buy something good for your kids.
I don't know.
I'm not your parent.
I'm not parenting your kid.
Wait, which trophy was it?
Trophy summoning spell.
Like if you don't want to buy it for your kids, don't buy
it.
Hey.
Cup overdrive, yeah.
I missed the part where it's my problem.
I missed the part where that's my problem.
Uh-oh, wait.
Is that...
I don't think I have enough room for...
Um...
For the, uh...
What's it called?
Christmas.
Uh-oh.
Maybe it's not fantasy.
anymore it's christmas for now yeah get that one take it
yeah nice nice nice
solving all my problems bully mcguire
adore how investment minto is to this game it's like so hard
not to be i wish i was half dedicated to most that oh that
guy is bamboozling me you guys came at the same I love my
rental store Sausage in Miami I want to tell you though ma
'am This is not An adult film Wow Rules are rules You don't
want to know what my parents did when I went on junk food
And they didn't want me to have it They didn't get it for me
That's what I'm saying I'm not the parent Oh Merry Christmas
Oh wait it's not Christmas yet Well then do you have a
Christmas movie for me You can have, uh, uh, the red-nosed
marine.
Tis the season!
Look at this one!
He's wearing a little wizard hat!
He's too cute!
Oh, this one's so happy!
Wow, they even got, like, dirt on it.
Like, a real inflatable.
Too realistic.
Wait, there's graves!
Wow, you think this place is haunted?
I don't think so.
I don't want to talk to me.
Yeah, I broke the last movie I rented.
What are you going to do about it?
I'm going to kill you.
Oh!
Galactic Rebellion.
There you go.
Wait, this one doesn't say reserved.
It's just here.
So weird.
Oh, probably because I just gave it.
Probably it was the reserved one and I just gave him.
Oh, that was my bad.
My dad left me when I was a kid.
I'm sorry, Dylan.
Do you have a family drama?
Also bad.
Okay, bad family drama, not about dad's...
Oh, here you go.
Knockout gangster.
Take it.
Or leave it.
Hello from 30,000 feet.
Concert yesterday was incredible.
Glad to have Minto for the flight home.
I'm a safe flight, dirty laundry.
I'm glad you had fun.
Wait, you can watch streams on the plane?
That's insane.
You can watch streams on the plane?
If it's over land.
What?
I thought they always said, like, don't...
Like, you can't... I don't know, actually.
Or...
Action.
I always thought they said don't stream stuff.
You can't make calls.
Oh!
Okay, it's just the calls then.
Dang it.
I was gonna be up in there being like...
Wah!
Wait, what the heck happened here?
Did someone get angry at you?
I'm sorry.
Wah!
Hello!
Yep, I have it for you.
I have it for you.
There you go.
This is why we drink almond milk.
No one ever hears about dads going to the store to get
almond milk and then we're coming back.
No phone calls and Zoom meetings.
Oh, my friend once did a Zoom meeting.
And I remember the lady coming over and being like, stop it
right now.
And she was like, whoopsie.
This recently booked my first visit to Japan.
faster.
Oh my god!
A sage will have the mostest fun ever!
Potential customer?
Future customer?
Wait, did I get you?
No.
I like how I come up from behind and just like slip it into
their hands, you know?
The Lactic Rebellion.
V1 King, welcome to Mambushab.
Thank you.
I usually just watch the stuff on the planes.
But I think recently I've been flying so much that I...
Like, don't have anything that I want to watch anymore on
the planes.
That's not true.
I guess there's a few things.
But I'm like, mostly I'm like, oh.
What?
I'm slim pickens.
So maybe I will start downloading some stuff.
I guess having like VODs to watch is really nice.
Did you ever watch Better Call Saul?
No, I haven't yet.
But I haven't watched the movie.
I wanted to watch the movie first.
What's it called?
You guys know.
I got this game because of you.
I love it.
I also love...
I also make mods.
Do you have any silly requests for this game?
Maybe an Aibu decoration?
Oh my gosh, I would love!
Aibu, yes, please!
El Camino, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That one, that one.
Spooky season.
Oh,
sorry.
Oh, you're already coming over.
We love Aibu decoration.
Yeah, I think that's everybody.
What just happened?
What do you mean, watch out?
Why are you yelling at Ryan?
I'll kill you.
In Minecraft.
Actually, no.
In Retro Rewind.
Why did he yell at him?
Make a candy.
ibu so we could be sold wait that'd be so cute too also can
you make an ibu adult film like the ibu and the t-rex or
something wait um who ordered the hot ibu
please please
you guys don't want that what do we got today i sell boo leg
movies what do you got milk the shipmate is in for a treat i
bet he is the rangers hitchhiker where voodoo dolls fall you
got an eye for the good stuff feel my no
thank you
feel my no i love the shipmate is in for a treat
That's a good one.
A classic even.
Have a good day, Ryan.
I'm here.
What's the long face for?
Alrighty.
$447.
We are going up in the...
We are going up in the world.
On it, boss.
One Ibu video.
A-B.
Coming up.
Oh.
Any suggestions?
Alakar, omakase, uh, free-for-all.
Whatever your heart desires.
And look at our movies for sale!
We are making so much cash on this!
Maybe we should just order, like maybe we should start
ordering like a heck ton of the new releases.
Ah, the smell of cheap plastic and old, old way, what'd you
say?
Popcorn.
Oh!
Yummy.
Let's get like 10 more.
And we can sell this guy.
Put it all out.
Oh wait.
Let's put this out.
And then we'll be able to sell these once it's no longer
popular.
And assign a job.
Return station.
we're gonna get everything kind of prepped and then I'll
call it here all our snacks are sold too you guys holy moly
no stinking away I think people like our store remember when
I first did this it was so hard to sell the snacks sometimes
but now stuff is like going like hot cakes I think I'll get
hotcakes for dinner.
Mod movie request, two Ibu's kissing, freak in the sheets.
I can't believe my ghostmate is this cute.
All solid titles.
I heard they're working on a joyful Ibu video.
Yeah, blazing enchanter.
Probably.
Speaking of Ryan, I psyched.
I'm psyched for Ryan Gosling's new Starfighter movie next
year.
Does that guy rest?
Wait.
Ryan Gosling is in another movie next year?
That guy has been in, like, five movies every year, I feel
like.
That guy is making...
That guy is crazy.
Acting is his job, I guess.
No.
He never stops.
Maybe it's his job.
Yeah, but like, you know, he probably makes so much money
and could take a break if he wanted to.
Dang it.
I didn't mean to do that.
I wanted to do only these ones.
He's right behind me.
Oh, he's just doing a little twirl.
Today I have my first time at Disney World and top off my
day with a side of Mindy.
I'm a happy camper.
P.S.
I'm poured out.
No, don't send a super chat then.
I know how expensive.
I know how expensive Disney is.
Wait, you went to Disney World.
How was it?
What did you ride?
Did you go on Rise of the Resistance?
Please say yes.
Do you have so much fun?
This year was Ace Combat year, so I can't wait to see more
people and VTubers playing Ace Combat.
Oh, none!
I'm so happy.
I have Ace Combat 4 next week.
I put it on my schedule.
Today.
Oh, whoops.
I wasn't paying attention.
What?
Yeah.
I put it on the schedule.
Sorry for that.
I haven't been able to make schedules recently.
Speaking of.
But...
I have...
Oh, drama movie.
Yeah, just put it there.
Um...
Oh, never mind.
I have...
I don't remember what I was gonna say.
I have something.
Woohoo!
You have a drama movie.
I have a drama movie.
Oh, yeah.
Um...
I really can't remember what I was gonna say.
That's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Take the drama.
Actually, we'll just make this a mixed one for now.
It's kind of, like, awkward.
It's, like, drama and Christmas and dramas.
Christmas and drama.
Sponsored stream?
I don't have a sponsor.
stream on sunday for the for pragmata or movie suggestion my
oshi's important announcement stream no well important
announcement maybe but exciting announcement yippee
my oshi's exciting important announcement stream
let's do five random movies mixed nice suit oh my god it's
all freaking christmas okay sorry snowman's medicine space
cauldron whoa this this uh it goes hard it's so cool santa's
mission the stolen duchess
decoration nobody wants that i didn't have to be all
christmas the elephant's perfect gift it's so cute stephen
left me for the android oh sorry i shouldn't have bought
another drama
okie dokie you get signed to check out what broke the trophy
summoning spell no
and then i save and we're gonna call it here guys thank you
so much for another thrilling day at my at my rental store i
had a lot of fun these movie titles i know they're so funny
i've been loving these comfy streams have a good rest of
your evening thank you you too Thank you, Targo, so much for
the pink.
Your story is looking so fly.
I totally want to rent movies and buy snacks here.
I'm going to dial up to CompuServe and post on my BBS.
What's that?
About it right now.
All my readers will come over and just do a wait.
Booyah!
Tribe, Princess, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, Paige, did I get your...
did i get your
your skills from earlier steven must have really wanted you
to grind those metal gears thank you again hope you're
prepared for all the ace combat controls they can be
intimidating yes i'm i'm i'm not ready but i'm ready to fail
but that's okay thank you mito happy hot cakeing and good
sleeps Can I get a family movie?
Say the saucy ghost.
I've been distracted.
I'm sorry.
Let me go look at them real quick.
Let me look at them real quick.
I just saw you sent them.
I'm sorry.
Thank you so much, though.
The book summoning spell.
I love it.
It's kind of expensive, though.
A knight's path to his woman.
but worth it.
The Legend of the Waitress.
Wait, this one's... I love the Waitress.
The Ranger... Wait, the placement is so funny.
It looks like the T-Rex's.
Why are these ones so expensive?
Oh, hail the sausage!
Immaculate choices.
Thank you very much.
I know all Ace Combat beginners know one maneuver and for
some reason and always on the ground for some reason.
Okay, let's save.
Asal Darko, thank you.
Why does my BBS really look different?
What is a BBS?
A Brazilian butt-smacking.
I heard Ace Combat 4 earlier.
I quite literally shot up from my couch like a sleeper
agent.
Well, I gotta get caught up.
right?
Thank you for the coffee stream, Vito.
Thank you, Fizdom!
Thank you!
Gizora, thank you!
Quick, what's your real life movie recommendation for the
night?
Besides Project Hail Mary, Shutter Island, because I watched
that one recently.
It was pretty good.
How did I get online without my modem screeching?
Anyway, loyal readers get to dogs and dinos right now.
They've got the best movies and snacks.
The owner is super cute too.
10 out of 10.
I know, everyone's obsessed with Ryan.
Oh run.
Look at that dashing smile.
Bulletin board system.
Oh.
I thought it was a Brazilian.
Butt smack.
Booyah.
Thank you everybody!
Thank you so much for more Retro Rewind.
Um, honestly, I enjoy this game so much.
So, it might not be like a weekly thing.
Or maybe, like maybe, just kind of whenever I'm in the mood
for like a cozy gaming, right?
Ryan's not the owner.
Oh, you're right.
You're so right.
Thank you for the straight rate, though.
I can't wait for an important announcement and exciting, an
important announcement.
PN.
No, no, no PN.
Sorry, wait, hold on.
Let me, exciting, oh no, important announcement.
And exciting announcement.
Yeah, well, actually, there should be.
exciting announcement soonish soon wait there's one exciting
announcement that i can think of and then another exciting
announcement that i can think of that one's on until a
little bit later but not too far and the other exciting
announcement is maybe end of next month and yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah guest for my concert.
I don't know what's the holdup.
I couldn't even tell you.
I'm so sorry.
Soon, Tim.
But yeah.
Exciting stuff is in the works.
That's why I'm busy, but it's for exciting things.
So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Busy, but for exciting things.
Yeah.
So thanks, guys, for being patient with me through all my
travel um i do have a few other things that i have going on
next month next month is also quite a busy month but um i
have two travels next month kind of crazy um one will be
very short one about a week again uh oof and I don't know
but two travels two travels but it's all going to be worth
it in the end once everything is able to come out I think
didn't you say we're moving soon too yes mind if I ask if
are you going to play one and two also I do I thought about
playing one before four but I wanted to really get caught up
on the story stuff so one will be eventually moving to where
that's such a good question there's been so much happening
behind the scenes that have been a little bit of my
stressors so you know when I'm kind of like all scatter
brand it's because there are many things that I'm like I'm
like, but obviously I try not to let it, uh...
Wait, I want to see what this guy's mask looks like.
Oh!
He's a shy guy!
My little shy boy!
Um...
But yeah, it's just been a whole thing, so, um...
But I don't want to talk about it, because I don't think you
guys need to worry about it.
I'm just going to stream and be as silly and goofy as I
usually am.
Takizo, thank you so much for the pile gifter.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Once things are settled, then I will talk about it.
Once things are handled, I'll talk about it.
Yeah, yeah.
Hope you figure it out soon.
Thank you.
Darko, thank you.
Yeah.
Hope it isn't a bad place.
Thank you.
Me too.
Yeah.
It's been a yeah one more thing I recommend you to play is
combat 3 as the last game for story related but yeah I do
want to play 3 but it will probably be further down the line
since it will take much longer SMG 4 what if Mario worked at
a card shop huh?
thank you for being so strong for us no no no no it's all
good you guys make you know you guys always make my stresses
go away too because honestly when i stream i have so much
fun with you guys so i don't even i don't even have to think
about stuff and i can just have a fun time so yeah i think
tomorrow we probably do tomodachi live and then saturday
finish bioshock and then sunday have pragmata uh sponsor
stream and yeah that should be the rest of the week so and
cute maids be this tough no no no so yeah we have some games
to finish up like uh bioshock and then that's why i will
start this combat
yeah yes yes yes yes yes yes yes sponsor let's go i'm
actually so excited for it though i'm really excited i i
want i actually wanted to play the game um so it doesn't
like you know it's sponsored but I'm like yes
yeah yeah it's a big sponsor I know I know thank you thank
you so much hope to see deadly premonition for our next
story game honestly maybe it's been a minute it's been a
minute since I played the frustrations of Alan Wake so maybe
we can put it on next I don't have full schedule for...
Well, probably not next week.
We could do Ace Combat.
Yeah, an Ace Combat next week.
Maybe we could do it.
I'll figure it out.
Is Minto Lickable?
If you don't mind, like...
The Curse.
If you don't mind the Curse.
You know what?
Let's...
I'll put Deadly Premonition.
for next week too i want a goofy wacky game my brain right
now oh brain right now is combat is i know that's your brain
all the time now a little curse is fine as a treat okay i'm
gonna go get some food now i'm hungry asavito everybody
thank you so much i hope you have a great day i hope you
have a great night i hope you have a great time zone and i
will see you when i see you next let's raid into is it
Matara so Matara is actually streaming so we'll raid into
Hoi her stream she's playing actually she's playing a game
that I played off stream that I really liked called
graveyard keeper which they announced a sequel for so yes
yes yeah oh wait yeah okay thank you everybody What's up,
Vito?
Have a good day, have a good night.
Bye-bye.
It's a nice show.
Sorry, my finger slipped.
My bad.
Sorry.
Oopsie.
What's up, Vito?
Bye-bye.